oh yeah we're live how's it going
everybody we're still here at Turning
Point USA thanks for for tuning in we
got some some some big news on this
which will be our last show of the Year
2022 and what a year it was I don't know
about you guys but I was glued to the
Kerry Lake trial all day and it was it
was rough because I'm just sitting there
I gotta work but I can't stop watching
because the testimony is riveting and I
believe that there was once again
bombshell evidence provided this time
from the people's pundit Big Data
polling Richard Barris very very
interesting testimony and then we got to
the closing arguments which in my
opinion I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
mince words I think the defense had had
a a good argument and the plaintiff this
is careless lawyers I think did not did
not hit hit the nail and head with a
hammer but we will see this really just
depends on whether or not the judge is
willing to adhere I suppose well I got
to be careful there's a lot of arguments
to be made I think based on what we've
seen already there stands there's reason
to believe there were significant errors
this is witness testimony this is uh and
data but it's going to depend on whether
or not the judge agrees it was
intentionally done to hurt Kerry Lake
which is let's be honest very very
difficult if not impossible to prove but
it does seem that the plaintiff
carolicks team did provide evidence that
there was intent at the very least
whether or not it was an intent to
actually subvert the election we don't
we don't we don't have that and that may
be where the judge comes back and says
Nope Carrie late you're out so we'll
talk about that plus this one's Crazy
Sam bankman freed somehow got his bail
paid for 250 million dollars it may have
been a 10 Bond or something but it's the
biggest Bond apparently in history and
and it was paid for and he's being
released we got to talk about that plus
this one's I think is Big new a new
story exclusive I believe this is Daily
Mail exclusive
Facebook Google and Twitter it's not
just Twitter are riddled with Former
Intelligence employees when I say former
I think only on paper so we'll get into
all that stuff before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member click that join us button and
uh you will get access to exclusive
segments from the timcast IRL podcast as
well as cast castlevlog Tales from the
inverted world and with your support as
members we will continue to do the
things that we do like coming down here
to Arizona to hang out with Turning
Point USA do these shows on set but also
we're building cafes we're building
physical locations we're launching new
shows we're going to keep doing whatever
it is we can to build a cultural
movement and actually have a Major
Impact so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends become
a member at timcast.com joining us today
to talk about this and boy is it perfect
we got Blake Masters
what's up great to be with you here
thank you who are you well I ran for
Senate here in Arizona in 2022 uh came
up a little bit short we'll talk about
that right I obviously watched the
security Lake trial today with Keen
interest and Carrie of course is uh is a
good friend of mine and um you know
before that I worked in technology I ran
Peter thiel's Family office in San
Francisco and then Los Angeles and so uh
so I've had one foot in the tech
investing world and one foot in the
political world for the past couple of
years and um and potentially the new CEO
of Twitter right here is that the rumor
we we will see almost certainly not and
anyone who wishes that for me wishes a
lot of pain for me we wished it for the
show like how cool would that be if like
Thursday comes around it just so happens
it's like Master CEO of Twitter oh but
you're right it's a curse it's a curse
it'd be pretty cool and I do think from
a product Direction like there's all
these interesting things we could do I
think you could actually make Twitter
quite profitable in five years I'm not
sure the balance sheet has five years
though right Elon I think right he says
he said it's on the path to bankruptcy
in what a couple months he said it was a
plane with the engines on fire the
country trolls aren't working but he did
say he thinks he can get it cash flow
even by next year which is is a good
sign so we'll see but uh I think he
should keep running it by the way I
agree that's when people say Blake you
should go on Twitter it's like I think
Elon can do a better job of it than I
can and so why wouldn't we just uh want
him to run it he's showing he can run
multiple multi-billion dollar companies
at once I agree thanks for joining us we
also got Luke hanging out hey guys very
simple message for you guys here today
two plus two equals five the truth is
whatever the government wants it to be
just don't believe the evidence of your
eyes and ears and you could be a trendy
slave by uh representing your uh larger
compliance with this shirt on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com because you
guys buy the shirts that's why I'm here
that's the best way to support me the
best politicalshorts.com because you do
that's why I'm here you should write
books like George Orwell you're good at
that kind of thing I I think so hi
everybody Ian Crossland here from Ian
crossland.net happy to be here happy to
talk to you Blake about tech and then of
course we'll talk about politics too but
let's just get down to it let's jump
into this first story man it's the it's
the last show of the year so we're going
to talk about Carrie Lake and uh I I was
watching this trial all day I gotta pull
up the story from Fox News because this
is just it's absolutely insane Fox News
publishes this story Kerry Lake's
opening Salvo an election fraud case
appears to fall short it's not a fraud
case Carrie Lake's trial right now is
about invalid ballots Lakes fraud
allegations didn't appear to explain her
17 000 vote lost to Katie Hobbs she did
not make a fraud allegation they
explicitly said they are not making a
fraud allegation it's crazy to me not so
surprising when even Fox News is not
telling the story correctly so I'll give
you the gist of what we saw yesterday
and where we're at today so yesterday
what do we hear
one witness testified that he was given
a sample of certain ballots and he found
that in all of the samplings there were
19-inch images printed on 20-inch paper
which we know from both the defense and
the plaintiff would the machines would
reject that we he then testified the
ballots were then duplicated but the
originals were not stored along with
them breaking chain of custody and
that's the one that's crazy to me like
is anybody talking about that like if
you fill out a ballot and they told you
to put it in box three and you did
because it didn't count they would
duplicate it and run the duplicate
through the machine and then they lost
the original so how do we compare these
two and know they're actually the same
that should have been brought up we then
heard from one witness that 298 000
ballots had no chain of custody this
one's simple the judge should have just
said to the defense can you produce the
chain of custody document in question
they didn't have it they didn't produce
it I don't understand how we're at this
point today we heard from the people's
pundit Richard Barris he said that exit
it polling returns for election day were
substantially lower than anything he's
ever seen ever I think he said something
like 72 percent when he normally looks
for around 95 to 98 returns and he
believes this is because people did not
people were not able to vote so thus
they did not come back
now this was challenged but he basically
said due to the errors they talked to
voters voters said that there were long
lines and there were tabulation machine
problems and because of that he believes
people did experience issues people
reported issues and thus a substantial
amount of Voters were disenfranchised
they argued against this today but I
think it's particularly compelling but
keep in mind it's not definitive proof
it's circumstantial evidence ultimately
what we end up getting in the closing
arguments
and this was really good for the defense
they said it your honor you instructed
in your uh in your uh ruling that the
plaintiff would have to prove
intentional misconduct with the intent
to to basically subvert the election or
flip it in another Direction and they
have not proven that
that's that's important because the
judge is going to be like you're right
you can't prove an individual acted
intentionally in an effort to hurt
Carrie Lake therefore even if the
ballots are invalid or otherwise doesn't
matter that makes no sense to me because
if I trip and fall and accidentally
subvert an election that election got
subverted so it would be no good you'd
have to do a new one it doesn't matter
what my intentions were but the but I I
guess as per the law the the judge ruled
if you can prove that someone
intentionally acted to alter the outcome
of the election then they would be that
that's what they that was the
stipulation for what they needed to win
and it appears the only evidence they
presented was that yes at I think it was
like six six locations they tested they
found the ballot tabulators were
misconfigured the only way the
misconfiguration could happen is if
someone intentionally altered the
printer settings it was not an accident
and then the defense contents okay and
even if someone intentionally did that
you can't prove the person who did did
it to hurt Carrie like therefore we win
oh that I mean that is a leap if you
intentionally do something
uh that subverts an election
what that doesn't matter if it was about
Carrie is not even it doesn't make sense
if they intentionally changed it to a
19-inch ballot then that was intent and
Blake what do you make of of this uh you
know court hearing what's your
assessment on what you're saying well I
think the standard that the judge is
requiring is even higher right it's
actually
Kerry's team had to show intent plus a
different result they had to show the
intent and the result would have been
different but for all of these changes
completely hard to prove we'll see what
the judge rules tomorrow right but
what's indisputable is that Kerry and
her legal team have shown they've just
put out in front of everybody all these
call them whether it's mistakes or
active malfeasance the election was
really messed up it was really messed up
like people went to go vote on Election
Day and the machines didn't work what
the printers did not work how does that
happen and and I think third world one
of the witnesses said 132 voting
locations there were issues
yeah it's like 30 of the voting
locations yeah it's really great I think
and Abe hobby day the Attorney General
right his election was certified as a
loss by like 500 votes and I know he's
in litigation too and they're doing a
recount but 500 votes and everybody of
good conscience knows and we sued on
Election Day to try to get the polls to
stay open for a couple more hours that
was rejected had the polls stayed open
one more hour Abe would be going into
his recount probably up a few thousand
votes because those votes on Election
Day were breaking heavily for
Republicans so Abe's was super close and
I think that obviously swung it carries
at 17 000 I think she has a good claim
that like hey if the printers worked and
people could actually vote when they
showed up that she'd be the governor of
Arizona let's let's let's let's argue uh
for the sake of argument let's say the
voter tabulation problems and all that
didn't exist
a witness testified that 298 000 ballots
had no chain of custody
how do how can you verify where those
ballots come from and then you actually
I'm pretty sure the defense defense's
own witness uh I'm not sure if it was
Jarrett testified like well yeah we we
didn't track that but by law they have
to so okay hold on there a minute if
if I was a judge and someone came to me
and said the margin 17 000. and these
290 000 have no chain of custody I'd say
well okay that's against the law new
election end of story I bet the judge
won't do that because the law doesn't
say hey new election right and I think
we need to change the state law I think
the state legislature should say hey if
you can't prove chain of custody you
can't assume that's a fair election but
it appears that the burden of proof
right now is on the Cary Lake team the
judge is going to say well hey okay
chain of custody that was broken that's
technically a violation of the law but
what's the remedy right you haven't
shown me that they injected new ballots
and that's probably impossible to prove
maybe it didn't happen right what what
happens to this state if the judge comes
out and says yeah you know it's against
the law to not have chain of custody but
uh too bad I mean what are the people I
have to imagine half of this state and
and and let alone how the elections
impact the rest of the country but I
mean if if I lived here and I was a
voter and I was told in the Press by the
judge and by everyone these these
ballots have a chain of custody so we
can't verify them but we're going to
count them anyway how could I have faith
in that system it'd be really hard to
and that's unfortunate right like
whether Republicans win or not like I
want everybody to know that their vote
counted I want everyone to know that we
have a first world election system and
the truth is that as soon as you
criticize our elections people call you
an election denier right well we have
better elections than some countries and
we have worse elections than almost
every Western democracy right and the
truth is somewhere in the middle and
apparently what we're learning in
Maricopa is you can botch an election
you can just botch it and if no one can
prove that you did it with the purpose
of putting your thumb on the scale and
that it actually mathematically changed
the result you can get away with it how
about this it was um Maricopa County
testified I believe it was like Maricopa
County correct me if I'm wrong please
double check all this I'm watching the
trial and there's a lot that SB Parts
through but they initially testified
that 19-inch ballots could not appear on
20-inch paper then when the plaintiff's
witness came up and said actually yeah
we have it and they published images of
this they come back today and go oh
actually we knew about that problem it
affected three other elections and it's
like hold on and he's like now we're
doing a root cause analysis of that so
but you said the other day it couldn't
happen now you're saying oh yeah we knew
about that okay so you knew that was a
problem it's been a problem you didn't
fix it to me it's insane that what we're
basically hearing is the election was
improperly done in two ways the ballot
tabulators were improperly configured
they knew it was they knew it was
improperly configured they're trying to
figure out how and there was lost chain
of custody on these ballots and they
would just be like yeah well you know
the crazy thing to me is this is the
will of the people the utmost of the
utmost importance for our nation for
each state for each jurisdiction to know
that we are governed with the consent of
the people but that they would come out
and the judge would be like yeah these
these call in a question the Integrity
of the election but we're gonna roll
with it anyway I mean I think people are
going to lose their minds if that ends
up being the ruling and I'll tell you
there's already a lot of appetite for
more election Integrity in Arizona right
it carries whole platform was I'm going
to go in and clean this up
whether you're Republican or Democrat
I'm going to bring more transparency to
the system right we're going to reform
all this stuff and now if we don't get
that opportunity
it's my heart breaks for people in
Arizona it's like why would anyone trust
it so Blake you ran for the Senate you
did not win
what's what's different about your
election how did it go you know what was
it well the margin is different you know
I think I was I lost by about 125 000
votes was the official difference
between Mark Kelly and me and uh you
know I think I drew a tougher opponent
and he's an astronaut and man he nuked
me with like 30 or 40 million dollars
right and and uh you know we thought
about suing and and was this you know
was this the right thing to do and
ultimately with all our analysis like no
it wasn't because as messed up as this
election Maricopa was you can't make up
125 000 votes like I don't think I won
the election right now right I have to
have enough Integrity to say that I
can't sell false hope to my people like
I said Abe hamide 500 votes
this stuff in Maricopa County absolutely
swung 500 votes now Carrie has the
interesting in between right 17 000 and
I guess that's that's what her trial was
and she's trying to prove that but for
this incompetence called incompetence at
best malfeasance at worst but for this
incompetence I would have won 17 000
votes we'll see let's let's let's uh
hammer that one down
let's say that Kerry Lake's initial
argument was I understand that it was
one big misunderstanding by everybody
nobody intended to do this improperly
but clearly we can see that the vote
margin could be different if not for all
these tabulators being wrong the law
could not remedy that that's right the
law requires intent it requires intent
and it's not could be different it was
different it would have been different
and that's that's a really hard bar it's
a really hard bar oh that's that's
insane that that's not real governance
real governance is saying okay what do
we know and let's apply remedy on the
facts they're saying regardless of the
facts there's a high standard that must
be met meaning they could the system in
place right now would actually put a
person in power who didn't win I'm
saying hypothetically
just because the standard is too high to
to to to to change it
I think it's insane because if I were to
do something like destroy someone's
property but I didn't do it to hurt them
that wasn't my intention my intention
was just like oh I didn't have an
intention I just actually destroyed your
house but I didn't intend to hurt you no
crime yeah apparently when it comes to
the you apply that to the political
landscape it's not a crime that makes no
sense I mean intention is irrelevant
when you're in talking about somewhat
disrupting and destroying things well
like if you're right somewhat somewhat
if somebody dies and it's no intense
manslaughter it's like if you're
reckless or whatever if you intend to do
it now it's murder but it's still a
crime it is still a crime so potentially
you could be driving in your car and you
could hit somebody and it could be
totally accidental and you don't go to
jail for it so the difference here is
that person still lost their life we
still acknowledge they lost your their
life you maybe still held uh liable
civilly we're talking about an end
process where one person will be the
executive in government in government
meaning there is a very simple remedy if
we can see that something lacks
Integrity in the election we hold a new
election because we're trying to get the
will of the people done right and Kerry
Lake's opponent Katie Hobbs was what was
her Secretary of State of Arizona during
the election her own election I think
even California has a law that bans that
right you shouldn't be able to oversee
an election that you yourself are
running in that's just even even if you
didn't do anything wrong that's just the
appearance of impropriety which is
corrosive to our politics so obviously
Katie Hobbs never should have been
allowed to be Secretary of State and
preside over this election obviously the
Republicans should have spoken out more
about Brian Kemp in Georgia for a
similar reason well it's also important
to note that I think the Republicans
were very divided this upcoming midterm
election we saw a lot of money uh that
was sent in many different places and I
think very surprisingly it was a lot of
democratic super Pacs that were
supporting a lot of the trump-backed
candidates uh but there's also an
article here by uh political that's
describing how Trump was splitting
donations With You Blake 99 2-1 was that
the truth because you were well
overspent uh because your opponent spent
way more money than you can can you just
quickly tell us how much your opponent
spent on how much you spent on on this
upcoming midterm election and where was
there their resistance because it seemed
like a lot of old Republicans didn't
want to give you money I have to correct
that a little it's a misleading headline
um it's true in so far as it goes but
actually you know on that list share
president Trump was was setting out
emails saying it done into Blake on my
behalf we were getting those emails it
was helping me grow my email list so the
benefit wasn't Financial in the
immediate term so much as that long-term
list building right he rarely does that
for candidates so it was actually a big
net benefit to me the Press sees that
and they're like oh Trump is screwing
Blake no that wasn't so when someone
donated a hundred dollars you got he got
99 you got a dollar but you also got the
emails from that yep but but and that's
a that's a common that's a common
practice but the media was just looking
to be unfair to Trump on that but so are
you saying that the emails he was
sending out was intended to fundraise
for himself but he included you on it or
was it intended to fundraise for you and
you took the Lion's Share but it still
benefited you more the former more the
former and you'd have to look at the
exact email copy or whatever but like it
was a common practice and they seize on
it right and then yeah so it's like is
that headline accurate technically but
it's misleading by by lack of context
the journalists um they pounced but uh
but yeah but your opponent over here
it's definitely so much more money than
you oh man a lot I so I I worked my tail
off right and I raised 10 million bucks
which is hard to do when the limits are
5 800 so we're raising money you know
phone calls couple hundred bucks at a
time couple thousand bucks at a time
adds up to 10 million uh Mark Kelly
raised about 70 million hard dollars so
it was about seven to one that's on the
hard dollar side and that's the and a
lot of it came from McConnell and the
GOP establishment I'd imagine huh I'm
half kidding by the way I don't think
that definitely didn't help me but but
they you know they sat out what's your
response to the story of democratic
super Pacs financing a lot of the more
populist candidates a lot of the more
trump-backed candidates this midterm
election because this is one of their
strategies and some people are saying it
actually worked in their favor and there
was Major Democratic organizations
donating to those specific individuals
I'm not sure that happened in Arizona
you know um people thought people
thought that was happening I've heard
that alleged I haven't really seen it
with my own eyes we saw it I think in
Maryland and in New Hampshire as well
um and it and it was like explicit and
overt just because they wanted to run
against balduck or something they yeah
exactly yep they thought it would be an
easier uh it would be easier to get
moderates if they pushed someone that
was you know more conservative or
further right
what uh what'd you spend the 10 million
on is that public uh I think it's public
yeah mostly um I mean mostly you know TV
staff obviously got to cover your costs
and and uh mostly we had volunteer door
knockers and it was a Grassroots lean
operation but uh but staff and then
mostly TV and advertising right TV radio
digital you got to get the message out
did you advertise on social media did we
what did Mark spend 70 million on same
stuff TV he nuked I mean just so August
and September as soon as I won the
Primary I won the Primary August 2nd win
by 12 points wasn't particularly close
August 3rd
the Democrat spigot just turns on right
and everybody is to every third
commercial is just Blake Masters is a
monster Mark Kelly is this great guy
Blake Masters is a monster it shows you
in black and white yeah yeah exactly
exactly all these right and you know I
know we're tempted to think like this
stuff doesn't work this stuff doesn't
work right people can see through it and
it's like well if if you if you go four
months uh and you deploy like 50 million
dollars against somebody telling people
that they're monsters they might
actually believe it on the margin right
which you know what I want to do we were
unable to overcome I would love to run a
commercial like it's too late now but
maybe I'll consider this in the future
where it's just like one of those
campaign ads where it's black and white
it'll be like Mark Kelly went to outer
space how do we know an alien didn't
replace him and then like did he go to
space or is it a good is a Boy Scout who
helps a church and then that's basically
the formula and it's not encased and you
do that enough and uh yeah and the
ballot harvesting right if you if you
and then they go together right because
I think people are really paying
attention people who have a a political
opinion they're not going to be I think
sold by Those ads but if if someone just
has in their subconscious while they're
trying to watch some entertainment right
Blake Masters is this horrible guy
because I've seen it 36 times in the
last two weeks then someone knocks on
the door and says hey have you filled
out that ballot yet no I haven't I might
not oh no hey have you heard Blake and
all of a sudden
there's a there's a vote in this system
by a low propensity voter I just want to
ask you just advertising is quite
effective I just want to ask you one
question just going along with this
conversation what did you learn from
this election and what would you be
doing differently if you could go back
and change anything
going back I think we'd have to focus uh
more on on early voting right harvesting
is technically illegal but there's
nothing illegal about tracking ballots
and actually raising money to go uh it's
almost a bigger project than one
campaign could do but certainly as a
party we need to get better at
understanding we got to be uh banking
votes early I think Kerry Lake and I you
know we we were working hard we would
fill gymnasiums 500 people thousand
people night after night we were winning
hearts and Minds we had the enthusiasm
we had we were look we were chasing
votes and the Dems had turned it into a
mathematical ballot chasing operation
very very early and you know as soon as
voting opened up in October I think they
were able to open up a lead and so we
got to get much more quantitative and
mathematical about it early on so uh our
uh reporter Shane Cashman he's acting
he's covering the Kerry Lake trial right
now very heavily he got to sit down with
Kerry Lake but he also got to sit down
with the a uh Kanye West who told and he
told me he's like hey man yeah he's
taking ballot harvesting really really
seriously and I was like that's what
that's the one thing I told him
and I told him uh before the show
started he asked me how do I become
president I was like he asked me three
times and he kept getting mad that I
wasn't answering him and I was like
because I'm not a political consultant I
was like okay fine a ballot harvesting
and he was like what's that and I was
like knock on doors tell people to fill
out the ballot have someone fill out the
form to properly return the ballot for
them then it doesn't matter what message
you have you don't need to go to anybody
and say Here's what I'm gonna do all
that matters is you knock on their doors
they just fill it out who cares and
they'll do it and I'm like especially if
you're if you're Kanye West you're not
going to say Trump bite in Kanye West
people are going to say Kanye West
celebrity so some states ballot
harvesting is legal some it's not in 39
States it's illegal and it's not in
Arizona it's not Technic it's it's
illegal in Arizona but here's how here's
here's what is legal right you can if
you have 15 million bucks and the dumbs
do this and Republicans didn't right to
our great detriment but if you have 15
million bucks you hire a thousand people
you assign each person here's 500
ballots right people their names and you
can go to their door and knock hey have
you voted we know you've got a mail-in
ballot and that person probably wouldn't
have turned it in but you can just keep
bothering them keep showing it be polite
but show up at the door hey have you
voted no hey you want me to stop coming
to your door
vote right now open up let me walk you
to your mailbox that's legal right you
can't do it and then collect them
physically and then so this is every
state in 39 States you can actually
knock on the door but I'll take it for
you there's just uh in I think it's 12
states have certain stipulations like
you have to sign a form as a caregiver
or something but there are many states
where you're allowed to knock on the
door and be like I'll take that right
for you to the mailbox and then you end
up seeing people coming and dropping off
tons of ballots but but I I'll simplify
it for you someone knocks on the door in
a city
and they say hey I see you got your
mail-in ballot and they go yeah and it
goes why don't you fill it out and they
go
all right I guess so who am I voting for
just just Democrat by okay and then what
do I do not just drop it back in the
mailbox right there at the front of your
door and the mailman will come take and
they go okay you're allowed to tell them
to vote Democrat these people are not
politicians who are going back on your
door these are these are activist
non-profits who are just being like as a
regular old person here's what you
should do that sounds like the
government telling Twitter to censor for
them like if just because they're not
politicians they're hired by politicians
to do it I I disagree look if I'm a
regular person and I knock on someone's
door and say I want you to vote for
Blake Masters that's just me as an
individual but if you've been hired by
the Masters campaign to do it it's
different that's very very different but
these are non-profits these are not
these are not the candidates necessarily
doing it to a certain degree they
probably do it to the legal extent they
can but what ends up happening is I
think I think one thing I want to stress
is that a lot of Republicans didn't
understand how Biden could have gotten
so many votes they didn't understand
this going into 2022 even and so we end
up seeing what should have been a red
wave come come in substantially less but
it's not so much that the votes didn't
come in it's that Democrats got a ton of
votes through through ballot harvesting
and Grassroots efforts which is totally
above board and legal except because of
universal mail-in voting laws and
because of absentee voter lists which
persist after the first time you sign up
it makes it extremely easy for urban
centers to get out the vote and very
difficult for Rural voters you are
mentioning that the rural vote didn't
turn out is that what happened not not
how we needed it to in Arizona yeah so
think about you driving out to a rural
area where every house is a football
field away from each other you knock on
the door you wait a few minutes then you
get in your car you drive down the
football field you park you get out you
knock on the door you wait a few minutes
someone answers they say sorry I'm not
interested you get in your car in in a
major urban center where you've got one
big housing unit with a hundred
Apartments you knock on the door no
answer you turn around physically and
knock on a door and you get an answer A
major advantage to Democrats because
they tend to be living in urban area
like you could argue it's like thirteen
hundred percent more effective or like
1700 more effective because the amount
of time it takes in a apartment complex
to go to like 190 people it takes you
you probably get to like seven houses in
the country or like nine twelve houses
in the country exactly like a 14 to 1
ratio that's a lot of time and gas money
uh
man and you know we got to be
self-critical some of this was
self-inflicted like Republicans you know
we're we're very into voting in person
on Election Day this cycle right the
good old-fashioned way and like I'm
sympathetic to that I I think you know
more people should vote on Election like
that's that seems like a good thing to
do right this this crazy extension of
mail-in uh voting and that we saw in
kovitz or you know and what what's the
left-wing wish list is just automatic
voter registration uh let's mail a
ballot to everybody 16 year old voters
pretty 16 year old voters pretty soon
they'll say like well let's just presume
that you voted the same way that you did
last time and then you have to opt out
you know I mean that look for that to be
on the the discourse in the next five
years but as long as we have this male
in voting regime we need to we need to
use it let me just say hey don't don't
let the Dems Bank votes and then we'll
all show up on Election Day well on
Election Day the printers might not work
right and you can't leave yourself in
this vulnerable position I gotta ask you
the tough question tough question for me
when I hear that you did not get support
from the from the Republican
establishment I can't say I'm surprised
it's the establishment but uh they're
not giving you the support meanwhile the
Democrats are are giving all of their
support to Mark Kelly that plays a role
in your defeat does it not oh huge
absolutely huge so my question then is
when they say we got to get Kevin
McCarthy to speaker of the house and you
know look I got I'm not a republican not
a big fan of the Republican party uh
more like honestly left libertarian but
I feel like the modern left is a weird
cult so I'm looking for whatever I can
get tends to be more so libertarian or
republican then they come out even
Marjory Taylor green who I like says
support Kevin McCarthy and I'm like
first of all I'm not in Congress I know
they're going to vote on it but I'll
tell you this I actively oppose these
people maintaining their positions as
Republican leadership when you look as
your your campaign as the as the best
example they could have done more at the
very least they could have done anything
to support you they don't in my opinion
I think they actively are working
against candidates like you and others
and then they think I'm gonna walk up as
someone who's never been a traditional
Republican and throw my weight behind
establishment candidates for their no I
I'd rather look simply put if Hakeem
Jeff freeze wins the speaker of the
house because you know a lot of the
Republicans in the house the freedom
caucus are otherwise don't want to
support the establishment I don't care I
view it as all very much the same I
don't know what your thoughts are but
that's where I'm at I care I think
Hakeem would be way worse than McCarthy
but I think we need new leadership I
agree both those are true I understand
where you're coming from I'm not yeah
but I do think he'd be worse but I just
kind of feel like unless there's a
reckoning for the Republican
establishment and there's a clean you
know what fine let Akeem Jeffries be
speaker if it means the current
iteration of the GOP establishment
disappears or is gutted and then there's
a backlash among the donors and
everybody says this was a huge mistake
right now the problem is they're saying
the mistake is to support you the
mistake was to support Carrie Lake when
it's actually the inverse the mistake is
to support people like McCarthy and if
we all do it'll be the same garbage all
over again 2014 will come around they'll
flub everything if Hakeem Jeffries does
win because a lot of people like me just
say I don't care about those people
people maybe then the donor class maybe
then a lot of the you know a lot more
establishment Republicans might be like
okay we don't we were gutted and we
don't exist as a reckoning for their
failures
look I want the Reckoning too but but it
might not happen right maybe Hakeem
becomes speaker and then the
establishment and the GOP side doesn't
fade away and then you have the worst of
all worlds right and so yeah thing in
politics what's the lesser of of two
evils or if you if you if you do that
don't you just get evil but that's the
situation the lesser of two evils that
brought us into our current political
landscape where we have a duopoly we
have one party not two parties that are
essentially uh ruling together on a lot
of the same issues that don't represent
the people the populist movement uh the
the people that used to represent the
people were people like Bernie Sanders
were people like Donald Trump and they
have foregone a lot of their policies
that would have helped people Donald
Trump right now is endorsing McCarthy I
think that's that's absolutely crazy
that he's doing so especially with what
happened with the the elections recently
um how do you Rectify all of this and it
for you what would be the solution here
how can we move forward in a way that's
more concise in a way that's actually
more reasonable in a way that actually
does represent and help solve some of
the people's problems I mean I think my
best answer is to just stay in the fight
you know I don't know whether that means
you know run for Senate again or run for
Congress or figure out a different way
to be involved um but I don't I don't
have a a one sentence answer we just
have to keep at it you know a lot of
people in Arizona after after the
election was certified said well we
should have just run boring safe
Republicans instead of Blake and instead
of Kerry and it's like well I I I gotta
tell you that wouldn't it wouldn't work
but but even if even if they would have
won it's like boring and safe
Republicans is is sort of what's
delivered us to this moment today and
the public is very disenchanted with
that Politics as Usual the unit party it
doesn't work and so we have to figure
out a way forward I think that way
forward is this kind of uh somewhat
populist America first you know policy
platform we just have to figure out a
way to articulate it that that is going
to win us elections we we had Miley
Annapolis on the show just after the
midterm and he explained to us Trump
supporters wanted Revenge the reason why
they were upset even though they did win
you know winning the house it's because
they want revenge they want to to feel
that there's hope they want to see a
decisive Victory I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be completely honest with you as to how
I feel right now when you know Marjorie
Taylor green put out that Twitter thread
supporting Kevin McCarthy for speaker
she made a lot of really really
excellent points that were very
convincing to me that uh Kevin
McCarthy's made some promises that
there's going to be investigations
they're going to look into the southern
border they're going to look into the
Twitter files he actually came out in
opposition to the Omnibus things that
are all really really great but while I
can reconcile that logically in my mind
I think long term I don't trust this man
I don't trust the establishment I
believe they backstabbed the America
First candidates and you know I got to
be completely honest I kind of want
emotional satisfaction I want revenge
that doesn't mean I'm willing to give in
to illogical thought processes I
understand your point on Hey Kevin
McCarthy's he's offering us this stuff
it's better than Hakeem Jeffries but
part of me is just like no I I think at
the very least
there needs to be some kind of effort
among uh whatever this this faction is
of more libertarian-minded individuals
that they cannot play this game anymore
so you know what if that means Akeem
Jeffries gets bigger thousand honestly I
don't care I don't I'm I'm so sick and
tired of it's It's it going on man since
I got into politics watching lie after
life failure after failure I certainly
understand how Luke's feeling with like
just get rid of the government just wash
it all away I'm at the point where it's
like well you know maybe Luke's right
but I'll take Let The Establishment lose
what little opportunity they had for
some power and then we can all laugh and
Kevin McCarthy's face and the Republican
establishment and then we can laugh
McConnell out of office and say you know
what we may not have gotten the power we
want but we weren't going to get it
anyway maybe this is just the Reckoning
they need and then they need us and I'll
tell you I feel really angry because I
feel like they really need me I am not a
republican I don't like Republicans but
I ended up voting Republican in 2012 uh
in the past I ended up supporting a lot
of Republic not just voting go putting
out having a shows and then all they do
is that I feel like they backstab people
like you they backstab people like
Carrie like the media lies about what
they're doing and I'm like fine I want
them now to lose they do not deserve
power if the Republicans would stand up
to Democrats like they stand up against
their fellow Republicans the political
landscape would be totally different and
they would be at odds but at the end of
the day that's not what's happening here
so how do we Rectify this how do we fix
this what what do you think about voting
online in addition to a current laws
with like a blockchain reference as
backup
in theory it works in practice that
terrifies me right no I want as little
technology involved as voting as
possible I think it's crazy that we have
you know tabulation machines uh where
the code is closed Source like you can't
actually tell what's going on right like
if you have it should be open source but
maybe you don't even need it at all
right like why not get back to Precinct
level voting the only technology that I
really want is high definition video
cameras trained on manual hands you know
reporting ballots uh and results at the
precinct level do you think upload that
video online and let the internet have
at it right like we want more
transparency and less sort of close
Source technology are you concerned
about like an open an open internet
voting is because it could get hacked I
just think you probably can't get there
all at once and the intermediate steps
would be uh extremely insecure Ian's for
a microchip voting by the way uh the
record here there you go that works as
well but I wanted to ask you is it time
for a new party because it does seem
like the larger populist ideas standing
up for the American people standing up
for the American middle class standing
up against the people who committed the
Jeffrey Epstein Saga there there's a
huge portion of those people on the left
and right there's also a huge portion of
people that don't vote in the United
States is it time to move away and and
have a political realignment here is
that possible a lot of people are saying
that this could possibly happen on the
Democratic side A lot of people are
saying this could happen on the
Republican side is that feasible from
your expertise in politics oh Is it
feasible no is it time for it yes I'd
say it's long past time for it right
we're never supposed to have this
two-party system it's like literally not
the government that our framers ever set
up or are really envisions I guess they
did Envision it they feared it and they
warned us about it
um but I think the the Republican party
and the Democratic party are probably
too established to um
to change it and maybe it changes over
time but and it definitely seems like
there's a there's a civil war within the
Republican Party within the old rhinos
and the anti-establishment but then
there looks like there might be another
civil war within just the
anti-establishment alone with DeSantis
versus Donald Trump with Donald Trump
attacking DeSantis recently so it's like
a civil war within a civil war this
doesn't look good it doesn't look
promising especially with the public
with the Republicans not having a lot of
institutional power to change anything
when it comes to ballot harvesting when
it comes to mail-in ballots for me
personally this is my assessment I don't
know if you think I'm too pessimistic or
too black pilled here but I don't see
the Republicans winning anytime soon in
in many years to come
I'd say the Saving Grace is the
Democrats really are that bad and
they're going to they're horrible
they're going to get worse and so if we
I don't know maybe we you know I think
we can do it by 2024 we certainly have a
lot of work to do I still think the
Republican party is the right vehicle if
you care about peace if you care about
prosperity and individual freedom and
all the things we care about uh I I do
think the Republican party is the
vehicle to salvage it's the most popular
uh
um
possible potential otherwise you got to
create something new and how much
Capital would that be nice
I don't think there's a way into
political power
you know at least right now or in the
immediate future unless you're going
through the Democrats I disagree I think
the internet video is super powerful
because right now if we ask people that
subscribe to timcast.com for instance to
vote for you or to defund you in a
campaign you'd get massive worldwide
publicity and money
I I think that if if I were to run for
office and did a show where to my
audience I said vote for me I would get
substantially less votes than you think
because a lot of people might like
watching the show or might like me
personally but they're gonna say oh come
on he's not gonna win and then and then
what's you know I'm gonna I'd rather
vote for someone who's got a better
chance and Ian who who dominates the
online space right who dominates YouTube
Luke who dominates who dominates
Facebook right who who dominated the
people that own them the FBI and who's
the FBI backing right now at this
particular time the Democrats in the
leftist and also the establishment
candidate so whoever plays ball in
Washington DC gets an unfair advantage
on big Tech social media that's a
reckoning that we can't underestimate
because it has a huge effect on what
America thinks not just on how they vote
so until there's a larger Reckoning here
I mean Twitter is one social media that
Elon Musk is putting everything behind
risking everything essentially exposing
the Deep state for all the horrible
things that they've been doing but
that's one element of it will we have
even Congressional hearings that lead up
to anything because of this well I hope
so but I kind of doubt I'm gonna pull up
the story here from uh we have a story
from daily mail this one's big
Spooks infiltrate Silicon Valley
Facebook is riddled with ex-cia agents
including president's briefer who now
runs harmful content team so many ex-fbi
work at Twitter they have a slack
Channel and Google is Rife with xcia so
uh there you go the intelligence
agencies run the technology sector uh I
I guess I'll throw it to you uh Blake
having been involved in the tech sector
what do you see with this have you
personally witnessed anything like this
or what are your thoughts
I we have personally witnessed like
Google coming down and and being unfair
right so when we were trying to build a
small dollar fundraising email operation
we would find a disproportionate amount
of our fundraising emails would get sent
to spam and Gmail well it's like that
doesn't happen to the Democrats right
it's not just anecdotal like we've seen
the data on this with with many
different conservative uh candidates so
it's uh it's just banal at this point to
say that big Tech has its thumb on the
scale like yeah big Tech hates
conservatives and we know that but what
what really got me was uh you know the
media and Carrie and I were running
against the media of course and and they
called me an election denier for just
talking about how you know the hunter
Biden censorship like I think that did
more than almost anything else to to put
Joe Biden in the White House oh well
Blake's denying the 2020 election and
then for Elon to go buy Twitter and now
subsequent to this 2022 election of
course but in the Twitter files and now
it's like the sorted details are out
there it is just demonstrable fact that
people at Twitter were censoring this
information with the sole goal of
helping Joe Biden win office this is
just not a conspiracy theory anymore
it's just true former FBI in Twitter and
current FBI Baker and yeah I mean so
it's really bad and we need to
disentangle it and and and and look at
how hard the media is going after Elon
um Elizabeth Warren is going after Elon
right deep State yeah this article by
the daily mails worth reading because
what you see is Agent after agent after
agent after agent after agent and you
see in the named and you see them in so
many positions of power but those are
the ones that we know about what about
the ones that are undercover what about
the ones that we don't know about what
about the ones that are compromised at
high level positions of power so there's
multiple layers to this not just overt
agents and spies working inside of these
big Tech social media companies there's
a different layer to this that again not
only shapes their companies but shapes
the minds of America and and I could
make the argument here throughout the
last few years overall social media has
been a net negative for the American
people it has led to a mental health
crisis it has led to a lot of debauchery
it has led to the destruction of the
family unit it is leading towards what I
believe is the great reset which is
essentially just this kind of larger
ideas this larger agenda that is
absolutely screwing you over and only
empowering the government so um they're
using it it's a psyop it's a
psychological operation and you are the
Target and you are the victim well but
so if you could say social media is a
net negative in 50 out of 100 was
neutral anything below that becomes
negative how negative do you see it uh
12 wow you so you think it's horrible I
mean that's really really a bad 25
percent
25 75 Bad 25 Goods there's some good
that comes with it but it's pretty
pretty bad I somewhat disagree I think
it's actually slightly uh more good than
bad and that's evidenced by before
social media the intelligence agencies
controlled media as it was I mean you
saw that in the church commission right
that the planting of journalists at high
ranking positions in media organizations
with with the internet it created cracks
and then channels like this start to
pour through other other creators people
like Steven Crowder start to pour
through they can't control every person
who posts though they try so there is a
net positive in my opinion it is better
than it was before but overall when we
look at the larger effects and again my
estimate again to answer your question
12 to about 25 overall when we look at
how people are affected especially how
children are affected by this when you
when you see
um the mental health negative effects
when you see women harming themselves
because it's trendy when you see uh just
the level of less interactions that
people are having the overall effect not
just politically but socially
financially economically I think the
overall negative uh it's a negative
effect to be honest with you politically
there are more voices that that are that
people are able to hear but they're
squashing on those independent voices
and and making sure that they reach less
and less people well I think this will
be reversed everything you're saying as
soon as Blake becomes CEO of Twitter
then we're going to say such a massive
net positive that the world becomes
better that's funny although I was just
going to say this is dynamic too
wherever you thought it was 75 25 50 50
right now it's Dynamic and I suspect in
20 or 30 years we'll know will this
internet and social media experience be
net uh you know liberatory will more
people be free and happy because of it
or will we be living in something like a
techno uh dystopia surveillance State I
mean look what happened to the children
look look at modern day children look at
look at attention deficitis deficit
disorder identity disorders identity
disorder look at the use of online adult
content by children look at those
effects that will be with children
rewiring their brains right now as
they're speaking to to have instant
gratification right to have their their
trophies to have uh just just
glamorizing them Living For The World
the living for the likes rather than
living for their communities living for
their families living for a future they
rather have this kind of you know a
selfie image of themselves glorifying
themselves rather than having an
importance on anything else around them
and let's talk about 30 or 40 years uh
Blake what do you think about neurolink
are you taking the chip I'm not taking
the chip I'm pretty skeptical I'm pretty
skeptical I like Elon is another um just
seems like uh seems like a
seems like a road you don't want to go
down like your brain will get hacked
yeah for instance
it's one bad thing I guess because if
you're well if you've uh uh have you
heard of ghosts in the show yeah so uh
in this anime people's brains or eyes
can be hacked you could be walking down
the street and also when you go blind
it's bad when Elon talks about how
neuralink could cure people who have
like paralysis or whatever
what people don't seem to understand is
that all systems are exploitable and
this could mean as well
that they could do bad things to you
it's not just about the things it could
fix about the things that it could hurt
they could make you feel like depending
on the sophistication of a neuraling
chip in your brain if it can cure
depression it could make you depressed
so you you think about how bad it could
get
it gets scary bad yeah I mean look at
the number of children having uh you
know a gender dysphoria that's been
going up as well that number is only
going to be going up from here what if
it could help people feel good about who
they are it could and it could it could
do really horrifying things where they
put you in a prison camp tell you to
execute the innocent children and then
you're like I can't do it then they
click a button on their iPad you go oh
this feels really good no I think like
social media is not bad or good but it's
powerful and if it's used for evil
that's powerful evil and the the neural
links like an acceleration of that yeah
neutrality Ian you shouldn't be chasing
what feels good you should be chasing uh
you know hard work dedication building
something growing something sacrificing
uh something in order to to have
something outside of yourself a lot of
problems with our society comes down to
I need instant gratification I need
instant uh likes I need instant
attention right now that's the route to
a lot of our problems
and that's the psychological trick that
they play on us in order to have us
engaged in these kind of larger uh
mirror devices I gotta I gotta give a
shout out to uh to Andrew Tate that's
that's the guy right Andrew Tate yeah
yeah Cobra Tate he's got a video where
he said I just saw this viral clip he's
like my happiness is irrelevant when I
wake up whether or not I'm happy or not
happy it doesn't matter I have to do the
exact same thing and I'm like he's
absolutely right dude he's so humble he
comes off so aggressive and like
um like I guess hubristic he even says
that about himself but he was just doing
an interviewer he was like dude I've
been a Pawn on the game for so many
years my coach would say run I would run
I would do exactly what I was told for
years of my life up at 4am run seven
miles I run seven miles I do exactly
what my dad tells me now he's in a
position where he can be himself and he
is the king of his environment just to
bring it back to the conversation we
were having his point is that your
happiness doesn't matter you have
responsibilities and so with the
internet instant gratification with
things like neural link that can make
you feel better these are shortcuts that
ultimately in my opinion will actually
lead to you being miserable and so if
you think about where neuralink gets you
you've got right now like the body the
fat acceptance movement the body
positivity stuff these are people who
are suffering these are people who are
more likely to experience cancer and
other health defects uh our health
health
um impacts due to their weight being
told to accept it and be happy with who
they are but it's causing them damage in
the long term you put a neural link chip
in someone's brain and then they're
unhappy about something so you click you
you click the button and then all of a
sudden they're happy they're not going
to solve their problem I'll put it this
way pain is a good thing if you can't
feel pain people people think like wow
unless you there are people out there
who can't experience pain they can't and
so a lot of people say you're so lucky
and they go no I'm not I could bite my
tongue off like I stepped on a nail once
and didn't realize it they can they
can't many of these people Can't Sweat
because their body can't differentiate
between temperature not being able to
feel pain is a bad thing we don't like
pain pain sucks but it's an important
thing that when you feel it you can
correct whatever the problem being
caused is if you can't feel upset
anymore because the the chip is just
correcting the problem you're going to
become lazy uh you're going to have no
goals you're going to be laying around
and you're just going to be a fat blob
lying on the floor clicking the button
to feel good that's like Soma and Brave
New World or anything exactly you know
the unwillingness to feel pain right
people or the inability two people think
that's oh that's a gift that's a gift
that's just the Midas touch like this is
just biblical you know be careful what
you wish for the Midas touches he wished
that anything he touched would turn to
Gold wouldn't that be nice gold gold
gold gold gold gold and then you know
give your daughter a hug and then she
freezes into a golden statue right oops
Yeah turns out it sucks and and it turns
out you're the CEO of Twitter
hypothetically
how would you make the company go
profitable
I think uh there's a path to doing that
medium term and long term you know
Twitter is the original short form
content it's really good at it now it's
sort of being you know competed away uh
Tick-Tock and Tick Tock should
immediately be banned of course right
and Twitter spring back Vine so there's
things to do but I think Twitter needs
to fill its feeds with longer Forum
products like I think Twitter needs to
buy Sub stack it should have built sub
stack sub stack should never be an
independent business like obviously all
these people posting on Twitter should
be able to monetize newsletters right
from in the platform and I don't mean
just the review feature that they had it
just was that was kind of bolt on wow
you should be the CEO and and like okay
so so video right Twitter sucks as a
video platform and yet YouTube has no
inherent social sort of viral social
network like Twitter does right so like
I think I think YouTube is very lucky
that no one at Twitter for the past five
years has cared about video yeah I think
I just want to make another Point here
because there's a lot of different
things that we could we could actually
do here I've been thinking about this as
well one we have super Chats on YouTube
why can't you have super Chats on
Twitter allow your comments and replies
to be voted just like Minds does mine
does a does an incredible things what is
it called Superman people are able to uh
put in a super chat if you answer it you
get that money that that people were
giving to you that's a great thing that
mine's developed another thing that I
would recommend Twitter to do is to
essentially allow the platform to run on
its own without any kind of major money
decentralize it let people host their
own servers let people use the platform
in their own way so then even if you
don't have any money the platform still
lives on and people get to host their
content and get to communicate with
people and also be able to share their
content elsewhere and move it around
with their history of what they posted I
think those two ideas along with your
idea would be amazing videos long
overdue monetize those videos have
people I mean when we had Periscope on
YouTube this was I'm sorry a periscope
on Twitter this was a way that engaged
so many different people and then
Twitter took it down because people were
dominating it that they didn't like in
the political ideas so so so
these are just some ideas that I have
off the top of my head
I don't want the responsibility get that
hot potato out of here
um one problem with videos is the cost
of the servers at least is what I'm told
and it is a big deal so we try to
decentralize it it mines like bit shoot
and and but it was so slow and grainy
trying to pull it from all these other
people I don't know do you know much
about decentralizing a video feeds not
technically although that's probably
going to only get better and better
right and I would look to add things
that uh people want to pay for right
like Twitter needs it's it's woefully
dependent on Advertising I'm not saying
advertising goes away but it needs to uh
certainly have new new revenue streams
where creators are getting paid for
their content you know what I realize
I'm paying eight bucks a month for
Twitter blue I am so happy to do that
right now I pay 40 bucks a year or
something on mines to have the uh
upgraded mines I'm not sure what it's
called exactly sorry Bill mine's Pro
mine's Pro to be on mines Pro and it's
like having a Netflix I don't have
Netflix account I don't watch Disney I
don't have those accounts I pay for the
social networks that I love that's where
I like to I would pay 15 bucks a month
on Twitter for sure for all those
benefits to be able to post long videos
to be able to make you a video like at
TAG Elon Musk hey man what's happening
bro
um that that access to this hey DMs I
think Elon talked about totally it's
great it's been Twitter's made it really
hard over the past few years for people
to actually make a business on Twitter
yeah which is really I I think YouTube's
done much better in this in this version
blocked link sharing recently and kind
of backpedaled on it link sharing there
was like you can't link to your whatever
social Bible social media which is
actually YouTube does the same thing to
I believe twitch does the same thing I
believe Facebook Facebook blocked Minds
do they still block mines dude Microsoft
blocks mines it's very weird
announces this uh this new policy where
it's like you can't use Twitter to just
promote other platforms and everyone
loses their mind and it's like YouTube's
always had that rule so like if you made
a video like subscribe to my Twitter
account and that was the title of the
video they yeah they'd nuke you so
here's what I'm saying I think they
mentioned paid DMs I got a lot of people
who hate me and they're they'll pay a
lot of money to set to say nasty things
to me and I will take their money and
they can so 100 bucks I will I will set
my my paid DMS at 100 and then all the
people who hate me can say all the nasty
things in the world and I will monetize
that and you have to respond and then
Twitter gets a small cut of it well I
don't know about responding just fill up
my mailbox well I mean like people could
do that yeah
I can't DM me I've closed DMS okay so if
they if he made paid direct messaging I
would say okay you want to direct
message me and I don't follow you 100
bucks you know and then you can send me
whatever nasty garbage you want you got
to pay me to do it and then a very
monetize the hate but you don't have to
read it you got to read it to get the
money you got to open the email that's
what I said I accept
I will read the comment of someone
saying you know Pim tool is a bald fool
or something like that if it's a hundred
bucks so what about totally worth I
brought this up before earlier reverse
only fans like a crypto token at Twitter
mine says a Minds token that's a utility
token that functions on the network you
can put a token into the network to get
a thousand views of publicity um then
you can buy the tokens and uh but I know
like you were saying earlier like SEC
violations you got to watch out for like
Library got raked for SEC violations I
don't know the exact but miles either so
the risk with the FEC is if they don't
like your politics well hey that token
is a security and that's just arbitrary
Elizabeth Warren could come up with some
justification for why yours is different
but like the justification is she hates
you and wants you cry if all it does is
get you publicity on the network that
it's sold on
um and then maybe used for fun cosmetic
stuff on the network I just don't see
any security involved in that it's all
utility at that point
I think you're right but they'll argue
it anyway yeah so you want to be on the
other side of the FEC uh enforcement
action because I think that could take
the company very profitable or at least
Elite very very very profitable I mean
obviously what would happen is the
Twitter token would become super
valuable and it would become traded on
binance and stuff and then they might
say hey and then it's a security camera
maybe yeah punished with your own
success but it's interesting though to
think how much they could raise if they
did that and that's that's not even
that's just the IPO or the Ico you're
talking about initial coin offering they
could raise money for I think then that
might be a security because mines didn't
do an Ico that's a big part of it that's
right they just make tokens and then
sell them and then you use them on the
network there's no there's no uh there's
no public investment the investment is
you buy the token
what do you think of the future man you
feeling optimistic
um not by default but I'm not not a
Doomer either you know I really think
it's contention it matters what we do
and and why wouldn't it like human
agency is really important if you're if
you're too optimistic and like oh things
will just work out well you're probably
not going to work as hard in making that
happen and then if you're just
fatalistic oh man it sucks oh I just
lost my election that sucks everything's
doomed no somehow that doesn't feel
quite right either it's like your mind's
scary but we got to work hard your
mindset and positivity does matter when
it comes to your overall productivity
and what you're able to do in life but
at the same time you got to be realistic
with all the problems and I totally
agree with you you got to have a balance
between between the two and have a
certain level of of uh you know basis in
reality but also some optimism on top of
that you know you know what gave me a
lot a lot of optimism was the judge
granting Carrie Lakes uh trial
I mean because everything we've seen in
the past has been dismissed dismissed
dismissed these judges have been weak
and just I don't want to deal with it
I'm not saying this judge is going to do
the right thing in terms of well I I'm
not going to say the judge is going to
give us what we want but the fact the
trial happened at all I think was a
major step forward in terms of
confidence so I'm feeling good I think
the night is always darkest before the
dawn I think what we're seeing with uh
James Lindsay you know the things he's
calling out and exposing with continued
success his his right his growing
prominence calling out the the groomer
phenomenon and I think Elon Musk buying
Twitter it's kind of like it's never
been better to be completely honest it's
true that didn't have to happen yeah and
if he didn't do that we never would have
got the Twitter files right I mean it's
what the coming installments will be and
uh look I have I have tremendous faith
in in the inherent goodness and I guess
just common sensical nature of the
American people and most people
worldwide and we have a political
establishment I think left and right
that is corrupt and doesn't work and
those things don't go together so how
long is the pendulum I don't know
hopefully things don't have to get that
much worse before they get better but I
do think yeah they'll get better and and
we've seen I think it's ebb and flow in
human history right I think we got to
work hard to tighten up that uh what's
the technical term for the length of a
pendulum I don't know whatever it is
let's make it short but the diameter but
but I think it is getting better I think
I think we're on the the backswing it's
starting to come back I hope so I think
with uh conservatives starting to uh
recognize the power of ballot harvesting
and ballot chasing I think 2024 is going
to be a game changer it's like it's like
you were saying it's about raw numbers
they're going after the raw numbers it's
not about the messaging for Democrats
about the raw numbers for Republicans
it's going to be both because
Republicans a lot of Republican voters
are higher information voters than
Democrats that's why Democrats want 16
year old voters they want low
information well Democrats will vote for
John Federman
you know where some of our voters God
bless them and we gotta work hard to
persuade them um but some of them is
like well I read some bad things about
Blaker I saw this TV commercial for that
it's like well
I I appreciate the individuality in our
party and we have a lot more diversity
in our party actually in terms of
diversity of thought but the Democrats
will vote for fetterman or anything Iraq
you've got it's got a D next to its name
and that's a challenge that we have to
overcome but but I think the Republicans
just need to Target those people these
these people who are low information
voters voting Democrat aren't voting
Democrat for any good reason which means
Republicans could win those votes they
just aren't trying to show up exactly
you need to show up what do you think
about like refocusing a message we've
talked about this for sure too like
graphene or some sort of
industrialization message of making the
United States an industrial superpower
just just a just a real quick preface
that like I think the point of the
conversation is that messaging is is
immaterial but again you know your
thoughts I think I think it matters
though and um you know while we're
working hard to go in in a legal way of
course you know Harvest ballots that
collect ballots
um I think interesting messaging does
matter for one like why aren't we
focusing more on nuclear power you know
earlier I only had so many campaign
dollars and we had to talk about border
and inflation and those are the top two
two issues but but every you know stump
speech I'd try to find a way to work in
nuclear power it's like this isn't even
new technology it's like old technology
that for bizarre reasons countries like
Germany have decommissioned right we
have about 50 uh nuclear power plants in
the United States nowhere near enough
most of them are decades old and so if
you care about climate change if you
care about you know Carbon free energy
generation why are we not going all in
on nuclear and when I would mention
nuclear power it was actually somewhat
of an unexpected Applause line and some
very right-wing Republican rooms like
obviously not going to get rid of oil
and gas we need to be drilling we need
to be fracking it's like all above uh
kind of approach is appropriate for the
next few decades but man 50 years from
now 80 of our power should be General
rated from from nukes at least if the
path we're going we'll probably have new
technology like vacuum vibrational
things and fusion power which is a they
call it nuclear it's a completely
different technology than fission so
there you can't really call them both
nuclear it's a misknown we've got to
lean into Innovation yeah as the broader
points like we should be agnostic about
what it is but like what it isn't is you
know some dumb subsidy for some wind
thing that is not even going to work I
think what's happening you remember the
tech in Texas two years ago or was it
last year the Deep Freeze that ruined
all these these wind power these these
windmills or whatever they're called
wind generators uh and we're headed in
like four a few days for another Deep
Freeze in Texas I'm told this is
terrifying people died people froze to
death in their houses because they had
shut down coal plants leading up to this
and I think that's why people are like
yes nuclear yes heat yes because it gets
cold if it goes down to 45 degrees in
your house nothing really matters other
than some heat that's right I think I
think Americans would be here for
whether it's a new party if you could
somehow bootstrap that into existence or
a Republican party that was like Hey
we're the party of competence We're the
Party of Technology we're party of
families We're the Party of sane trade
deals and and you know the party that
doesn't want to get into Wars halfway
around the world I think people would be
into that I think it's like we need
Charisma too like I used to think I was
telling you earlier like I was like oh I
didn't actually mention you were saying
you're a republican we were younger I
was like a Democrat when I was younger I
like I went after Charisma I was always
drawn to like Bill Clinton because you
like Howard Dean no no was that the guy
yeah Bill Clinton Barack Obama I like
the dudes that could make you feel good
and it's only later I'm realizing like
oh I've been snowed this whole time and
they were making me feel good to get me
to get me to pay my dollar so but I do
think we need to introduce Charisma but
the thing is like Luke you were saying
don't vote for political parties I don't
care about the party I don't I thought
in 2007 we don't need parties anymore
man we just need someone that's willing
to step up and do the work you're right
but that I I don't think um takes into
consideration the political reality
that there are a lot of people who won't
vote outside of the two-party system out
of fear of not winning and that has a
substantial impact the libertarian party
does a great job of getting a lot of
people of principle to vote for the
libertarian party but they they don't
they don't move the needle
what do you think you just do it enough
and then how did Abe Lincoln win look
the Maga party is not the same as the
Republicans and that's why there's a
republican Civil War at least what the
media calls it the reason why I think
the establishment didn't support you is
because you're you know Blake you're
more libertarian you're outside the
Republican Party
in in a in a uh literal and and a an
intangible sense like quite literally a
Republican but as far as the established
Republicans are concerned the mag
Republicans are a different party and
they're an Insurgent group coming in
that's right and we're going to get an
interesting
um I guess case study here Kirsten
cinema right the other Democrat senator
from uh Arizona just announced I think a
week or two ago she's going to be an
independent oh yeah I think probably
because she read the polls and realized
with her voting record it'd be
impossible for her to win a Democratic
primary so now she's daring yeah the
Democrat establishment to run a Dem
against her I thought that was awesome
at the race into a three-way race which
I actually think would favor a
republican so we'll see how it shakes
out but can a independent actually make
a real go of it right I mean Bernie
Sanders caucuses with the Democrats but
of course technically he's an
independent
Force the Democrats to keep her on as
their candidate when when Cinema said
she was an independent they they
immediately knew they could not run
anyone else and they can't primary her
they have no choice but to get behind
her well we'll see if they have that
kind of discipline I think Schumer wants
the situation you outline but this other
Congressman Reuben Gallego sort of
communist guy from from Phoenix
he really wants to get in and I hope he
does right and then you know grab the
popcorn are you gonna are you gonna run
again if Gallego gets in then that gives
me a lot to think about because in the
freeway race I will win or I would I
would beat guy I go one-on-one when
would that be like four four years or
what oh no no 2024 2024 yeah Cinema's up
in 2024. and so you could but the demos
might yeah but the Dems might actually
have enough discipline to keep uh keep a
damn out I think you should run anyway
hey there you go she's tough to beat
she's tough but Mark Kelly was tough to
beat though right and I think um you
know some people say oh Blake you lost
by five it's like Oz lost by five in
Pennsylvania and he had a way worse
opponent and 30 million dollars for
Mitch McConnell right so I think in a
different year
um with the you know and look I made
some mistakes too like I didn't run a
perfect campaign and I've been
self-critical about that and next time I
do it I will tell you this I will be
better and I will win I live in West
Virginia I instantly like Cinema more
than Mansion because she because she
comes out as an independent and Mansion
is still playing this ridiculous game of
being a democrat in literal Maga country
what's gonna happen there I feel like
he's now he's underwater right I think
he's gonna is he just gonna switch I
think he's gonna switch to being a
republican he was asked and he said you
know something like we'll wait till
later talk about it or something like
that which made everyone immediately be
like okay he's mansion's gonna switch
this is I think West Virginia is like 86
Trump supporting yeah you know every
County I think in 2020.
absurdly high you know I I where where I
live in West Virginia it's right-wing
nut jobs who who believe every single
conspiracy theory you can think of I
mean these are people who are Trump
trump hands down and then you say
mansion and they go oh like he's
supposed to be on our side and it's not
even about the name of the party they
feel like he's not representing them
properly nut jobs a term of endearment
by the way it is yeah like when you when
you go to West Virginia and you say I
love living on a mountain full of
right-wing nut jobs they all laugh and
smile because it's like it's taking the
word back you know I mean they say if
you're sane in an insane world you're
actually you look insane you look like a
nutshell we we had we had we had a
break-in recently
I think it was targeted but I I tweeted
I was like you got to be insane to break
into a house in West Virginia especially
if it's like a political thing and I was
like just imagine breaking into a house
and there's some right-wing nut job with
a Barrett M82 pointed at you yelling
Yeehaw and like all the people out here
are laughing at the idea because they
love it they love it they're like that's
us you know don't don't come and
knocking if you don't want to see what's
on the other side do you think Blake do
you think the solution to I don't know
what what do you what is your end goal
really with the United States or in your
lifetime how would you like to see the
United States develop
I I think one litmus test for or are we
on the right track is is politics boring
again like I think politics should be
boring it shouldn't be what people are
investing all their time and emotional
energy into I would like uh campaign on
the slogan to me it's more than the
slogan but it is I think a good
political slogan in America you should
be able to raise a family on one single
income I think if we got back to an
economy where you could actually do that
maybe it's really hard in a globalizing
world but man if you could just if young
people had Economic Opportunity and were
you know on net choosing to get married
and have kids in their 20s and we're
able to buy and afford homes and people
didn't have to be obsessed with politics
right we weren't at each other's throats
all the time I think that would be
really healthy do you see how politics
is pop culture right now yeah that's
right that's really messed up yeah it's
really messed up was um what was his
name Schumer was dancing with Stephen
Colbert did you see that video they were
unfortunately I did see that I had
forgotten about it I did it you said
earlier like it's a it's a worldwide
movement I think you mentioned that
earlier but I sense like worldwide that
humans want freedom they the First
Amendment of the United States
Constitution is like one of the most
inspirational governmental Act actions
ever taken on Earth and I feel like we
have so many people from Australia that
watch the show and England and all these
great countries that unfortunately get
can get arrested for standing outside of
someone's house uh and I hope that maybe
that they're I I kind of see like a
United States of Earth where we have
like state rights still but we just are
have like a form of kind of a sort of
Unified Government I don't know if
that's two pieces globalist in a way I
mean I like I think inevitably we're
globalizing I just want it to be done
right I want it to be done so that we
maintain our Bill of Rights like a
republic where the United States has
Sovereign borders where we control our
own government but there is some kind of
legislative system externally that can't
interfere internally with the nation but
can help prevent Wars yeah and even Ohio
still has its Sovereign borders and
right every state still has its own
rights like Alberta for instance I think
there's an Alberta secession movement
right now Alberta becomes a state of the
United States of Earth and then
we just keep growing from there and then
everyone lives under the Constitution
yeah but the Constitution's malleable
but yes yeah I think the Bill of Rights
for sure maybe I I think it's a good
idea maybe in order to to get to that
point you know some people will have to
be made to understand so perhaps we
could like put together a group of
people with perhaps weapons that could
go in and tell these people they now
live under our way of life and uh we we
we would call it like a Liberation we
would send out Liberation forces to
others that's horribly
commonly goes back to Woodward Wilson
right the League of Nations exactly now
it's the U.N and let's just have a a
layer on top that will help it and it's
like well the danger is that you know
that that layer becomes incredibly
bureaucratic and powerful and it gets
more power for itself and pretty soon I
think this is where the the century is
trending if we don't uh resist it you
get a one world totalitarian government
I like the idea of like China wants to
build its version and China wants
everyone to be Chinese in 100 years and
uh we actually nope we've never figured
out a way to to do that in a safe way
and I think we should look towards
decentralization that's right absolutely
decentralization is the key word here
that a lot of people need to focus on
more than ever as there are a lot of
American Western Elites financing China
setting up policies in the united states
that allow China to take over the world
that allow China to gobble up all the
resources that allow them to pollute as
much as they can and then everyone else
is supposed to be under these climate
regulations these these these Echo uh
you know fascist kind of policies that
limit people's ability to have energy
that's absolutely it's absolutely crazy
what's happening in this ever
globalizing world uh but but how is it
going to change I I don't know that's
that's just a very hard question to ask
but I also wanted to kind of talk about
Peter Thiel a little bit because I know
uh you were closely associated with him
I don't know if you you still are he's
kind of a Libertarian some people call
him more of an internationalist how
would you kind of pick his political
understanding and what's kind of his
response to everything that's happening
right now I mean the New York Times
calls Peter and me far-right
nationalists you know so it's like are
you an internationalist or you're far
right nationalist you know those are
kind of incompatible are you libertarian
or are you an authoritarian right so
it's so publicly used to think Peter
like me started very libertarian and you
know to the extent uh we play in
electoral politics it's Republican
conservative
um but I think you know you can't really
reduce him to labels like that like he's
actually kind of an independent thinker
imagine that right you can't just we
don't have that
increasingly we don't that's really
dangerous and and one problem in
electoral politics that I've seen is man
you're supposed to really stay on script
and if you know and sometimes I didn't
and I paid for that you know it was kind
of conventionally speaking it was a
mistake but the problem in modern
politics is you're not allowed to be
wrong ever because if there's two
seconds of video where you say something
wrong maybe you're exploring an idea
right but if that's wrong and if it's
cuttable and pastable into a into an
attack ad that Mark Kelly and the
Democrat machine puts 30 million behind
well that's a problem for you if you're
never allowed to be wrong then you're
never allowed to think which is why so
many politicians feel like wind-up dolls
right robots that just say the say the
thing that the Consultants wrote and
that's safe and then like what kind of
politics does that produce the kind of
politics we've had and it fails people
outside of uh the tremendous amount of
money he made for the social
ramifications do you think uh Peter
Thiel is has concerns about funding
Facebook or regrets or PayPal yeah
PayPal especially yeah well I think it
is probably really sad to see I mean
because PayPal he hasn't been involved
in since 2001 I think 2002 they sold to
eBay and to see it become I mean a this
extremely profitable business right uh
that's probably nice but to see it
become this woke horrible and PayPal is
one of the worst and I know Peter agrees
with that and so that's got to be hard
to create this thing and it's your baby
and then all of a sudden it's like
ruined by watching your kid go to
college and come back with a shaved head
and like pink eyebrows telling you about
racist and bigoted
so it's gonna be horrible
um Facebook I mean Facebook was a really
good investment in 2004 he you know he's
it was it was a good investment and then
he he sort of rode the wave and saw it
become like this really charismatic
company 2008 2012. Facebook was going to
take over the world 2014 right when we
wrote this book about zero to one
monopolies kind of warning people hey
monopolies can be good you know they can
also be really really bad
um I think Facebook is has been net very
destructive for the past five or six
years and ultimately Peter hopped off
the board right so it's this whole life
cycle I think starting in around 2008
Facebook started getting really really
really bad it was it was the the
beginning of the algorithmic news feed
when people started having too many
friends and liking too many pages and so
the feed was just moving too quickly uh
I could be wrong with my understanding
is Facebook started to implement an
algorithm where it would feed you more
of what you they thought you would like
to see to keep you on the platform
chamber confirmation exactly then you
see the transformation of the buzzfeeds
the Huffington posts they started
adhering and fall and molding themselves
to the algorithm and the best example of
this is mike.com which when it started
was was Pro Ron Paul but quickly
realized the algorithm favored wokeness
and it's for it's a really really simple
mathematical equation right
in the beginning of the internet or I
haven't at the beginning but in in the
late 2000s early 2010s the Ron Paul
Revolution was in full swing it was it
was a meme it was viral people believed
in it the algorithm starts becoming more
prominent and what happens is Rage
inducing content gets more clicks and
gets more shares so police brutality
videos start going viral this
contributes to a lot of the libertarian
thinking
but
then
something happens if you make a video
about racism it goes virally make a
video about police brutality it goes
viral so that's uh you know X views and
Y views but you make a racist police
brutality video now it's XY views it is
Multiplied it is bigger all of a sudden
you start seeing articles from like Vice
where it's like you know
um gay people uh gay trans people of
color are the the strongest argument in
favor of black lives matter to cram all
of those words into one article to
maximize algorithmic pressure and you
end up with intersectionality and
wokeness being Amplified monetized and
profitable
people hijack the really weak artificial
or the machine learning algorithms and
then when they went Prof uh public
Facebook went public they started
charging people Monies to to get your
own followers to see you as part of this
that's right algorithmic boost I
remember in 2011 we were working with
mines and this this Facebook group
called um exposing the truth which was
hugely popular and then as soon as they
went public man no views and everyone
everything was pay pay pay-per-view what
happened when Facebook went public we
had Vivek ramaswamy on the other night
and he was saying they were expected to
have like a 55 public offering when they
go public I suppose stock supposed to be
55 it came out like 18 bucks and then he
said it was like a wealth distribution
thing like intentionally they well you I
think that the point of the conversation
was maybe that was the exit for you know
intelligence or other uh nefarious
entities that wanted to get their money
out of the machine somehow like they
wanted people that were honest Brokers
to baby like oh I'm bailing on this and
then or just to not buy or something
they were dumping their their connection
to it bad time to dump because I'm I
mean Facebook stock exploded and you're
subsequent to the IPO
you realize you did not want to sell I
mean what is it currently I haven't
checked lately but and I want to say
2013 2014 2015 that stock did incredibly
well what were you doing with Peter
Thiel no I know you're working with him
in San Francisco what was your role uh
just managing the the family office you
know just always trying to find the next
thing to invest in and so his his
investment company teal management
company and the cool thing about Peter
is while he's I think the world's best
venture capitalist right or certainly
top three but I think he's the best um
he's always you know it's like
one minute you're talking about what to
what to invest in the next minute you're
talking about you know China yeah and
and what's going to happen in 30 years
and then peak oil and like what's the
deal with that and then he's just he's
truly intellectually omnivorous is he a
peak oil believer uh I
have to ask him I think he would have
said yes 10 years ago and no not so much
it's a very contentious idea that I
believe uh I don't I don't actually
believe in but would you say his
principles are more aligned with uh
making money or sharing kind of his
larger uh libertarian more right-wing
ideas because when you have you know so
much power and influence you're either
motivated by let's make all this money
or let's let's promote these principles
he did support he did have uh I think
backing of Ron Paul and then went and
supported Donald Trump
um in the last election so I was just
wondering from your perspective and if
it's too personal you don't know it's
actually personal I mean I don't want to
speak for him he'd probably come up with
some cut why those were like actually
you know not mutually exclusive and why
they actually compound if you if you
pursue both goals at the same time or
something like that being used to find
Peak oil what is that that that's a
theory that there's the the oil is going
to be running out there's not going to
be enough oil and therefore we need to
get off oil immediately because I think
it's true I just I think the question is
how much oil obviously there's a finite
amount there's a finite Earth so the
question is is there so little oil that
we might run out
or is it that it is finite but there's
so much human could never begin to
consume all of it yeah I don't believe
it to be true because a lot of the
science is also backed by a lot of the
people who are saying you know the
world's going to end in a few years
because of the climate so we see a lot
of the same rhetoric for the same people
we always it's a it's a decade it's
always a new problem it's always a new
controversy yeah there's an alarmism
right too because that never quite pans
out ioc saying the world's going to end
yeah the ocean levels are gonna rise the
ice is going to the and then it was the
ozone layer a couple decades before that
and then what was it a couple decades
before that there was always something
going on Cooling in this global cooling
yeah global warming oh it's always not a
good argument in my opinion because a
bunch of regulations were put in place
and cfc's the ozone is fine now yeah but
the sensationalism so that that actually
gives them brownie points when you make
that argument because they're like oh
yeah we banned the things causing that
we fixed it so I I I say you know look
it's it's not uh um one or the other we
had global cooling now we have global
warming that gives me pause the ozone
layer things an entirely different issue
yes I'm just I'm just talking about the
kind of talking points when people are
saying the world is going to end every
decade we should that was one of the
talking points and the parameters of
what you were described we just got to
start a new one we got to start like um
how about global tremoring acid rain is
also another thing artificial
intelligence that's what Global
tremoring uh or more earthquakes are
going to happen because uh cracking
that's a real one that's a real one too
you know but I was gonna say like the
the the uh the earthquake in San Andreas
the San Andreas fault's gonna go because
insert human activity here it's all the
uh it's all the humans doing jump rope
jumping up and down shaking the ground
it's gonna stop nobody no more exercise
real one is we might get hit by meteors
if we just sit around on our hands for
the next 300 years
um it wiped out previous civilizations
solar flare
solar flare is going to wipe out all of
our electrical equipment hard to tie
that one back to the human causes but
it's you know that's why it's always
concerned it's the TV it's all of the
the radio waves we're messing with the
yeah that's bouncing right now the two
real ones one um which is which is more
of a slow boil is China I really do
think China is a is a existential threat
long term unfortunately right we're
already in some kind of cold war with
China and we need to make sure we win
that so that we never get into a hot war
with China and then speaking of hot
water it's nuclear power I still are a
nuclear um War I still think we're
underpricing the risk to having the
Russia Ukraine situation escalate into
an all that nuclear war wait so you
oppose giving zielinski 45 billion
dollars I do did you opposing wearing
green Army fatigues when he went to the
White House or everyone was like people
I think that you should have worn a suit
who cares I don't care like they're
giving away they're gutting this first
of all I'm gonna just come out and say
it I know guys I went to the White House
I didn't wear a suit either but that's
not the point the point is I'm not
concerned that a dude showed up not
wearing a suit I know a lot of people
are talking about the decorum of the
white house I'm like bro I'm less
concerned about that more concerned that
they unfurl the Ukrainian flag and then
say the Mitch McConnell's like the top
priority for our Broward calls to
support you crying at least that's what
Republicans think it's like no that's
what you think dude regular people are
kind of like why is gas expensive when I
saw Biden put his hands on uh zielinski
I was like oh I pictured him thinking
and said hello
presidential puppet hello thank you
because he's a puppet they put him up
and they put him in power in 2014 when
they forced a revolution in Ukraine then
they just installed this guy I know
maybe it's not something I will tell you
as a candidate for federal office if you
oppose giving unlimited amounts of money
to Ukraine uh they will call you a Putin
puppet that's right that's like
how dumb is that like Putin's bad the
invasion's bad I condemn it okay it's
like we should look for ways to to get
those two countries to the negotiating
table and we all want to ceasefire right
but remember when Rand Paul just stuck
his neck out and said hi I can't block
this you know I forget it was 40 billion
at the time but if we're gonna send it
can we at least get an inspector General
assigned to it can we get a spreadsheet
so we know if this money is just being
wasted or if it's just being stolen or
what did you hear zielinski's wife went
on like a shopping spree or something
40 Grand or something they say if you
want to see who our next enemy is look
at who we're funding right now I keep
hearing that pop up and I'm like wait so
is Ukraine are the Ukrainian Nazis our
next war in six years
off Battalion when Russia uh assuming if
Russia ends up winning for whatever
reason and then all those weapons are
sitting there among pro-russian factions
and they get armed and then start
fighting against us I wouldn't be well
they're not just sitting there there's
also intelligence reports detailing how
there's already a a very uh booster uh
Black Market already in Europe right now
with many of the advanced U.S weapons
being sold to of course criminal gangs
probably jihadists that I have that that
now have surface-to-air missiles that
could take down airliners and airplanes
so you know when we're just sending
weapons down there without any
transparency or accountability that
that's a recipe for disaster this is the
same Administration and government that
says it's too dangerous for you to have
a handgun with so many rounds in it but
they're sending surface-to-air missiles
on the black market to Europe right now
which is absolutely mind-boggling here
here's what I think you know that 45
billion dollars I would rather they
spend it on a gigantic sign floating in
outer space that says Vladimir Putin is
a very bad person
because at least it's ours and we're
spending it as we choose instead of just
giving it away to Ukraine to fund a
proxy war granted let's be real it's not
even a proxy war anymore it's just it's
a NATO confident they were really avert
about it they're like they are our
allies here's the Ukrainian flag I don't
know if they said Ally what do you
what's your vision of a ceasefire and
drawdown of the militants in the Ukraine
right now
I mean I think we basically know the the
Contours right it's like I mean so the
problem is Ukraine definitely wants
Russia out of Crimea I don't think
that's in the U.S interest I don't think
U.S is going to force that right uh if
if Ukraine is simply not allowed uh to
join NATO and that's our Line in the
Sand but they can join the EU let the
Don bass have a plebiscite they can
figure out who's going to rule the dawn
I mean I think you could draw this I'm
not like an expert in this stuff but I
think you could draw a peace agreement
that gives Putin some face-saving
ability to get out of this thing because
it hasn't worked well for him uh it
gives Ukraine most of what they want and
it de-escalates so that we don't
actually have nuclear missiles flying in
six months it just feels like Biden on
you know on
I don't know I actually don't know how
with it he is right but it feels like
he's kind of just in zombie-like fashion
marching us towards nuclear war yeah I
don't think the chances that are very
low but of course the costs of that are
so high I mean we're talking if the
missiles start flying it's like two
billion people dead in 48 hours well you
can't have that and so why are we even
flirting with pouring more gas on the
fire by sending this money in this
unaccountable way it's a real problem I
don't want to be Cavalier about it but I
fear that if you just put oxygen on it
are we actually threatening to make the
problem worse and no one has been able
to give me a satisfactory explanation
for know why this is super okay and this
is this is de-risking it I just think we
might be adding risk to the system and
it's really complex no we're escalating
it every time we we are every time we do
that we stop the possibility of any kind
of peace deal moving forward and there's
a big possibility of a limited nuclear
war there I think also this conflict uh
allows China to be stronger it allows
them to have more influence especially
with the the the the actions that are
happening because of this war affecting
the poorest people in the world China's
kind of stepping in uh while there's a
big crisis that's been that's built in
there and I kind of wanted to ask you do
you see China or Russia as the bigger
threat to the United States
um because they're also working on crazy
projects with Bill Gates with many
nuclear reactors they're working on a
lot of uh you know technology that we're
not working on here they're they have a
lot of money especially from Western
Elites I see them as kind of a bigger
threat myself what about China's a way
bigger threat this is not debatable it's
like Russia under Putin I think he's bad
you know whatever but but but no it
they're in commensurate right and one of
the risks by the way of just punishing
Russia with so many sanctions you throw
the kitchen sink at them you you they're
West risks pushing Russia into the arms
of China right China would love that
China would love to have Russia as some
sort of quasi-satellite uh State and
this new new alliance new access against
the West right why would we why would we
do that that we should try to get out of
this war with Russia and Ukraine right
we should try to force them to have a a
ceasefire and then ultimately I think
it's all hands against China
the CCP I imagine you mean yeah CCP what
happens if you can't conflate all of
China with a CCP but actually you kind
of can as long as the CCP is in power
because that's how totalitarianism works
it's important I think it's important to
differentiate between the Chinese people
because they're under that regime as
well sure yeah absolutely basically
modern slaves I look at like eastern
Ukraine I think you mentioned the Don
bass region there's two freeways that go
down into Crimea and I wonder if there's
a ceasefire and we end up there ends up
being like what what two freeways are
this this is an interesting philosophy
East 97 and East 105 those two freeways
that go down into Crimea I mean Russia
wants a land bridge down to Crimea you
could give the Western Freeway East 95
to Ukraine and East 105 to Russia and
just have some sort of peaceful
alignment I know that zielinskian is
it's Lindsay's very much like Ukrainian
national sovereignty we're not giving up
our land and and period that's it and as
long as if the United States is funding
that message I don't I don't see it hap
happening I I think we really need an
American push for a ceasefire but to
blockade Russia from the Black Sea makes
no sense like when the Soviet Union fell
apart they gave Ukraine all that land
basically to neuter Russia to make sure
it didn't become another Global hegemon
but at this point it's like yo it is a
global hegemon it's one of the third
most powerful country in the world next
the United States and China probably
um and I think you know I don't know you
make peaceful Solutions
that's me from the outside looking in
over there is this in politics
I need to go to Moscow with Lex Friedman
as my translator or and you Luke well
you don't speak Russian right now I
don't um but you're polish there's a big
difference between the two and then I
need to go to China with Jack besobic as
my translator and then they'll have
their own translators that will and
they'll be keeping each other and
they're going to give you the intrusive
covet test up here you know what it
happened I would do it I'll do it if it
means Global Peace I'll put it up my
butt
you heard it here can we get that uh on
a meme can somebody meme that right it
happened yeah send it to me for World
Peace wow that's that's very brave of
you thank you sir yeah you're the hero a
lot of these conversations I kind of
feel like
we have no idea what's really going on
that these intelligence agencies know
way more about International Affairs
than we do they don't justify or explain
it to us for
reasons of retaining power but also for
for security reasons so we're probably
sitting here saying all this stuff
they're probably sitting back in their
offices going like you have no idea yeah
I'm sure that's right and then also the
opposite is somehow probably right like
you know maybe with all their
information they actually uh don't know
what's going on either yeah right or
remember wmds that they're in Iraq yeah
well were they really or were they not
or was that just lie to us it was a
psyop to convince America the American
people to support the war just like the
Gulf of Tonkin yeah no they knew there
was no wmds there was uh weapons
inspectors that came out and they were
silenced they were ignored by the media
they were gagged by of course the
federal government there was individuals
the only chemical weapons that Iraq had
was the ones that the United States sold
to them when they were at uh war with
Iran and they were and the US government
was was financing both sides of that
conflict both sides of that war and they
knew there was strategic papers out
there showing specifically you overthrow
the government of Iraq you're going to
have Sunni wahhabis take over the area
you're going to have massive of
sectarian violence you're going to have
Iran's fear of influence be expanded and
growing in the region which is not for
the American strategy which is to align
themselves with Saudi Arabia and the
sunnis so this was a recipe for disaster
and they knew this they had it all
outlined they knew hey we're going to be
hitting a beehive here and causing
problems for the next few decades ah
screw it we're gonna do it anyway the
political policy papers were all there
everything was lined up I was screaming
about this I was there you know I was
saying this is absolutely crazy this is
insane there's no wmds this is just the
project for a New American Century
realized in real life
you're on the same age as you know like
me and Luke I think I think me I think
he might be the youngest person here but
like 136 what do you got 36 but your
birthday's in August March and then Luke
when's your July you guys all 36
shout out to the 36 year olds out there
but I'm bringing this up because I'm
curious of you know back during the the
Loose Change era the Ron Paul Revolution
were you following that stuff oh yeah I
was a big Grandpa guy in 0.708 yeah and
I I assume like many others that leads
you to this position right now but I was
just wondering I mean I'm I'm wondering
I mean I definitely would have preferred
John McCain to Barack Obama really oh
yeah I see Mr I see quite a bit of
difference between them but zooming out
not as much difference as I would have
liked and then you had Ron Paul who was
basically like talking about the set of
questions that nobody was talking about
and
um I forget how he did in his primaries
I mean it wasn't the revolution did not
happen right but it's still Galvin has a
lot of people like you said earlier
people believed in it and I think you
actually got
did he get like 10 in New Hampshire or
something they cheated him they cheated
him in so many different ways especially
when it came to the polls especially
when it came to the corporate media
coverage I remember following that they
won't they wouldn't listen yeah they
screwed him over as John McCain was
literally singing songs about bombing
Iran so and also we have to understand
what happened with Barack Obama was a
direct result because of the mistakes
not mistakes but because of the
destruction of the United States caused
by George W Bush George W Bush was put
in a position of power he abused that
power he destroyed the American
Constitution he destroyed the American
economy and because of that we had a
cultural pushback just like we did
during Vietnam and the JFK assassination
where of course we had the leftists
become more prominent mainly because in
my opinion according to Bush
overreaching doing too much and becoming
a totalitarian leader which he was I
thought Obama was an example of like
hoping that we can put an innocent
charismatic guy in Power and hoping that
he'll save us like a superhero and like
he gets in and gets co-opted like
everyone else in that position when
reality we need a ground up movement and
he promised like I'll be there for you
and I think had we done a ground up
attempt at like some sort of Internet
economic Revolution that he wouldn't
have said no he would have sat by and
let it happen like he was he was looking
to do it but he couldn't do it from the
office there's too much that's the
fascinating thing about Obama is he ran
on Hope and change and it's supposed to
be discontinuous from Bush right and he
he effectively harnessed voters
dissatisfaction and I'm something new
and and actually his administration
represented stasis and continuation and
lock-in and Wall Street got even richer
and the Patriot Act got even more
fortified you thought drone strikes
under Bush were remarkable well Obama
just you know just they called him pedal
to the medal on that oh bomber and you
they called him deporter in Chief
Patrol guys on uh on the campaign they
would say you know Trump was great solid
a but then they'd say not to be partisan
about it like Obama like B Biden F in
terms of how these administrations
supported us right like Obama actually
understood it and go back to an Obama
speech from 08 or 09 it's like he sounds
like a right-winger on immigration he
says well obviously a country has
borders and if you just let anyone in
you don't know who's coming in then you
can't have a country you know it's like
wow you say that now and wow you're a
bigot but that was Barack Obama and oh
wait I'm not sure if he believed it but
he knew the politics of the time were
such that he had to say that I would
love to get just to talk to Barack in a
room with no satellite phones beaming in
and listening and here like you know how
co-opted did you get dude I know that
Michelle was trying to do the let's move
campaign get off sugar it was sugar is
bad for you let's move and cut sugar out
of our diet and then the sugar industry
came in it's like no no no let's make it
an exercise campaign not diet so I was
like okay now let's move is now an
exercise campaign sugar industry you're
back in back in business okay Katie
Couric does a documentary better than
ever right didn't the let's move
campaign it's like they they you know
saturated fat is bad we're gonna ban
this two percent milk from schools and
instead they introduce like strawberry
flavored skim milk which is like cancer
and you know tons of sugar but hey it
has no fat high fructose corn syrup and
Seed oils good intentions can actually
backfire surprise we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kind
of a kind that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends my friends this is the last show
of 2022 because tomorrow everyone's
gonna be traveling so they can be with
their families on Christmas Eve
Christmas is on so Christmas is on
Sunday and we were like well Saturday is
Christmas Eve we don't want to make
people travel on Christmas Eve so we're
gonna let people travel for those that
need to travel the Friday so we're
basically going to wrap up and then the
next week we had a couple of people
interested in coming on and then we got
cancellations and I was like I don't
think we can fill a full week to be
completely honest plus nobody likes
working after Christmas not to mention
Monday is a travel day after Christmas
so I was just like let's just take the
week and stop trying to swim uphill swim
upstream and uh uh you know I don't like
taking days off but we're not going to
resist we're gonna have a good vacation
and uh we're gonna see our families but
uh for now we're going to read those
super chats so again smash that like
button we got Kyle who says Blake should
move to Kentucky to challenge McConnell
in the next election if not Massey
should do it I think Massey should do it
Massey's awesome yeah what a national
treasure that guys I got the chance to
meet him a couple months ago stand-up
guy obviously very funny on Twitter and
uh he's a model Congressman he's really
great yeah no comment on moving to uh
Kentucky to challenge McConnell oh Jazz
says Tim I'm sorry to disappoint you but
I really liked the new Avatar did you
guys see the new Avatar movie nope nope
nope haven't nope I I I don't want to
see it I probably will for cultural
reasons it will probably be a fine and
entertaining movie but I just really
just don't like it I hear it's very
culturally appropriate and uh
inappropriate inappropriate and
appropriative yeah appropriative and and
not woke enough so that's why I won't
see it people have said it's good it's
probably James Cameron directed it yep
he says that uh testosterone is the
toxin in the world
I mean you can you can get too much tea
you know balance your teeth oh we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr Tim last Super Chat
of 2022 a positive note my folks told me
they'd never again voting Democrat just
because they're Furious about porous
border billions to Ukraine and our
government not caring about its own
citizens Hey look it's a positive
positive things are happening border the
the southern border man uh Jorge Ventura
is down there just doing God's work and
the amount of videos and transparency
he's providing for people to see these
people being trafficked across the river
day after day after day after day for
years like what in the hell that is I
I've never seen anything like millions
of people literally millions and then
the White House Press Secretary says
that's not how it works people will just
walk across the border and it's like no
millions of people have walked across
the border since January of 2021. this
is why yeah I can't believe these voters
these these voters are so stupid but I
guess they are like there's videos of it
but people I know personally are like no
that's not true and it's like can I can
I pop the video and show you what
happening like you're lying it's a right
wing trick oh okay you're an occult
sorry dude it's so weird
all right here we go Andrew Bruce says
tried sending a meme of Joe Biden
walking with zelenski with a
photoshopped Hunter Biden in the
background to my mate on Facebook
messenger and I got hit with a violation
and got logged out of Facebook well I
mean why were you making fun of Joe
Biden you know have you thought about
how maybe you deserve it could you
believe this guy trying to make fun of
Biden like that yeah thank you call the
FBI call the FBI well they already know
because you know they're on Facebook
what do we got
oh hi there says love you guys thank you
for helping to keep sanity an insane
world see you in 2023 I think our
January 2nd show is going to be really
really big I think we got a really
awesome guest maybe can we say who no
got it because it might not happen this
is how it goes yeah you know like for a
lot of guests uh they'll say yes and
then a week goes by and like oh no
something came up and then we'll go find
somebody else so if we announce it then
you know just ends up not happening
sagas of history says I want my I want
my MTG now look at them establishment
that's the way they do it they Omnibus
spend on the gender studies that ain't
working that's the way they do it your
money worth nothing and they take the
kids for free
oh I get it's to the tune of uh that
song Money for Nothing is that what the
song it's called Dire Straits yeah good
one sting sings on that oh what
[Music]
oh MTG I want my MTG
that's the way they do it best
gas addict says spending my birthday
with you guys if you don't fix something
that you know is broken and it breaks
that is malice end of story yes that's
what it seems like if you break it
whether or not you intended to break it
you broke it and it needs to be fixed
Matthew under says the law in Arizona
doesn't require intent to provide a
remedy it requires either intent or that
the number of questionable ballots put
the results in doubt the judge conflated
these
I think that's right actually and the
question is when the judge conflated
them is that the new standard somehow it
shouldn't be but it's a legal ruling I'd
understood the it to be you have to show
uh malice basically malice or some sort
of innocent mistake that was enough to
change the result the question is have
they shown either then it seems like
what yeah well but but the question is
will the judge say they've shown either
here's the important issue
um evidence is not proof
okay so so having Witnesses provide
circumstantial evidence is not
definitive proof and the example I give
to people is you come home from work
your chocolate cake is destroyed it's on
the kitchen floor and there's paw prints
in it is that proof what do you think
happened the dog ate it no that's not
proof the dog ate it it's proof the dog
stepped in it because then you walk over
and there's the cat with chocolate cake
all over its paws and the dog's got
nothing on his mouth so it turns out the
evidence did not prove but let's say you
see the cake knocked on the ground it's
a vanilla cake this time because dogs
can't eat chocolate and there's a paw
print in it the evidence suggests to you
I'm gonna go check the dog because
there's a paw print here that's evidence
and when you go to the dog he's got
icing all over his face okay that's the
proof the evidence brought you there so
in this sense what we have is evidence
was presented to the court sworn
testimony affidavits all of that stuff
more than enough in my opinion that the
court the judge should the first thing
the judge should have said is okay
defense can you produce a chain of
custody documents that they they say
don't exist
first question he should have asked
because the answer is apparently no but
okay at the very least the evidence
presented should result in a hard
investigation from an independent
process where they go in to make a hard
determination on the facts so they can
say we have evidence we followed the
evidence here's what we found
I'm worried the judge is going to be
alike
you know have a nice day
so we'll see
we will see we will see
you know but but it is it is good that
he granted the trial in the first place
because it's more than we've seen in the
past
all right Sam urai says if GOP began to
harvest anti-fun BLM will hunt the
people in the ground game
in the streets we we will lose 2024 the
same way we are done nah I'm sorry
that's too pessimistic for me I actually
think people bring up Orange County
Republican bad harvesting is introduced
turns Democrat Republicans figured out
turns Republican again
so I'm fairly optimistic actually I
think especially with Elon Musk I mean
that was a nuclear bomb dropped in the
culture War just massive very good news
let's see what we got
Joseph Flynn says the past six years are
the result of the 60 years of groundwork
the political Elite have laid down we
don't have 60 years to undo their work
how can we win I like you all but
Alternatives don't work against evil how
does this not end in open violence open
violence is the victory path for the
machine The Establishment and the left
that's why they have locked people up
over January 6 for two years without a
trial because they know how to control
that because they know regular people
are scared the path of Victory is
confidence building and confidence
breaking that is in a fifth generational
War or conflict you you have to win
hearts and minds and with cameras on
every street corner violence doesn't
work when I mean look at all the police
brutality videos that went viral there
was a period at the end of 2000s where
like every video on Facebook was police
brutality that was devastating to
government Pete like you ended up with a
whole wave of Libertarians and
anarchists being like abolished the
police
so what what works is
being being on the side of Peace being
on the side of Charisma influence and uh
you got to win some elections and change
some rules and change some laws that's
what we got to do
but uh I suppose it's a question of if
there is no reconciliation then people
get violent and that scares me
all right essay federali says Tim hit
the nail on the head Milo was right look
at what people who care have had to deal
with I want revenge I mean I gotta be
honest I'm I I just don't feel like
whatever Kevin McCarthy says is worth
anything to me but I I understand what
you're saying Blake when you're like
he's certainly better than Jeffries you
know Marjorie Taylor green has pointed
out he's offering a whole lot and I'm
like I guess if you're a republican that
makes sense there are certainly things
he's offered that I want but I just
don't trust them never never have never
will and at this point I know you may
not feel that way but I'm like I
understand that most people do but I
mean looking at how they abandoned you
and at worst may have actually actively
worked against you I'm like dude these
people do not deserve my support sorry I
ain't gonna happen but I I do think you
know if you're at least willing to try
and uh keep a cool head about it that's
that's honorable
don't look at me I'm I could be a hot
head sometimes so but a lot of people I
don't agree with the Revenge narrative
and I'd like to talk to Milo by the next
time I see him because I feel like
that's French Revolution territory where
they were executing people by beheading
for uh you know just I'm not talking
about dance well that's what yeah that's
what happened I'm talking about firing a
guy you know what I mean like you're
fired guys holding people up to to
accountability is one thing but trying
to harm them physically uh you could say
that firing someone is a form of harm
but I'm not talking about that kind of
harm I'm talking about like when I say
Revenge I'm saying fire him
and if it means the Democrat might win
the speaker I just I don't know if
that's all that much different in my
opinion then let's let's call it
righteous accountability how's that and
I'm talking about rights your rights
they have rights they have human rights
Revenge doesn't imply violent action it
just implies an emotional satisfaction
of some sort has comeuppance to a
perceived slight or something my
attitude is just these people have never
represented me I've never been a big fan
of them and I feel like they were
actively working against the people that
I cared about and and thought were
trying to help me
I see a lot of candidates and they're
like we want to make your life better
I'm like I really like that they want to
make other people's life better I really
like that and then I see the GOP
establishment being like we're gonna
hurt them and I'm like okay I want them
fired this isn't a side just fired I was
listening to Mitch McConnell on a video
man he sounds tired compared a couple
years ago I haven't heard from him in a
couple years I haven't heard his voice
and it's just like it's time to retire
man yeah all right Midas says Luke a
government will always form in all of
history every Community has turned into
a government it's how it is the key is
to form the best government possible the
founders made the first honest attempt
now it's time we do it again and better
yeah we talked about that on the after
show and I we kind of went to the same
kind of conclusion there there is a kind
of government but I think the best
government is decentralized government
and I think we should be pushing for
that more than ever and slowly make sure
that we are more personally responsible
for ourselves and don't need government
how big of a local police force do you
think is is justifiable depends on the
uh I mean
like a community of like 100 people or
thousand people like honestly like like
it a lot of it depends on culture but
for me personally like none
well I mean just like how small
communities will like police themselves
they'll be like all right Luke you're
the one that has the best accuracy so
you're the sheriff and then it like and
then it scales up to a thousand people
are like well now we need like nine
police to take care of this or 13 police
and like like how do you keep it
decentralized as the community
local militia and courts
but like as communities grow I feel like
the militia grows and like then when
it's no longer centralized because the
most headquarters is three miles away
you got to think about it in terms of in
the early days of this country when
there was a more common morality not
saying it was all good obviously there
were bad things but if everyone in the
neighborhood took action to protect
their community community you wouldn't
need police to a certain degree because
if someone started doing something
illegal everyone would turn and be like
we have to stop them nowadays most
people are like leave me out of it so
then someone has to be appointed to stop
them and even the cops are going leave
me out of it and they're watching
violent crimes having to be like I don't
want to get involved you know what I
mean so like meanwhile the left wants to
get rid of qualified immediate actually
we might disagree on that right but like
they want to get rid of qualified
immunity which is really going to keep
police on the sidelines what does that
mean exactly I mean the cops are pretty
much when the sidelines already but but
they are like yeah and or or they're
they're the good cops have already left
yeah did you see what happened during
black lives matter the cops were just
standing by literally they didn't do
anything very often they're ordered to
stand down exactly
or just saying I'm not going to take the
risk so let's put qualify immunity is
that if they put their held responsible
for their actions the left wants people
to be able to sue individual police
officers in their individual capacity
for anything that goes wrong well you do
that then no cop who needs to respond
sometimes you do need to respond to very
dangerous things right with with
physical force and so if everyone's
thinking I'm going to get sued for this
personally like who's going to want to
be a cop like it's already I'm in favor
of that really I think we should have
less cops and more guns
I agree with the more guns maybe the
numbers actually we actually think we do
have a disorder problem on the street
and we need more police officers
but when more police officers they're
going to only be enforcing what the
Attorney General in that particular
District wants them to enforce and
that's usually the wills of George Soros
going after people in your political
party that that's a disaster here's a
better here's a better example Illinois
it's illegal for someone to have a gun
if you are a law-abiding citizen in all
circumstances and they find out that you
as a father of three terrified for your
neighborhood and your family illicitly
acquire a weapon they're coming after
you if you are a gang leader surrounded
by a bunch of guys strapped with a whole
bunch of I mean modified handgun you
know modified Glocks for Fallout or
whatever they're gonna stay away from
you that's right so what happens is the
cops are like hey I'm not going to that
neighborhood those guys got heavy guns
but this father he wants a gun so the
problem ends up becoming look if you're
a cop I totally get it do you want to
walk into gang territory where their
intent on killing you with high-powered
weapons
or are you just going to arrest the
low-hanging fruit so my attitude is like
growing up in Chicago
I actually think there's a there's a
potential for accidental discharge and
things like that there always is but
what I saw all of the criminals know
they can rob you all the criminals know
there's nothing you can do about it they
don't care if they go to jail the way
they talk because I know so I I grew up
with some of these guys they say things
like I have not gone to jail yet
they expect it to happen me I don't want
to go to jail and I'm not going to break
the law so when these guys walk up to
you with weapons and knives and guns or
whatever they know you don't have one I
would much rather live in a society
where they see me walking down the
street and they can't tell what that
thing is in in near my waist under my
jacket so they go nah not that guy not
that guy
because it could be the end of your life
or it could be permanent injury but the
problem with places like Chicago is
they're like dude's probably carrying a
phone he doesn't have a gun gun free
zones right only law-abiding citizens
respect gun free zones the criminals so
I don't I don't I don't want to put it
on the cops I don't think it's fair to
say officer you stand in front of me
when that guy's threatening me no no
don't worry I got it I got a second
amendment if that guy wants a threat in
my life I will protect myself both are
good an armed citizenry is good and and
well-trained supported police are good
if you don't have selective enforcement
The Selective enforcement is really bad
right it's described intercote tyranny
right like we're not going to apply the
law but over here but we are over here
that's what we have now
actually actually you make a fair point
um I I made this point before that if if
you go back in time to when there was a
more unified cultural morality
you're driving down the street in a
small town you get pulled over sheriff's
deputy gets out of the car and he goes
Blake
I told you last time not to speed now I
got to see your dad down at the pub
tonight what am I going to tell him when
the community was closer with each other
when they saw each other at church when
they knew their neighbors or he'd pull
you over and be a license and
registration you handle me and go
Masters are you John Masters kid that's
you I you know I see your dad on the
weekend sometimes down at the the range
or whatever and I'm gonna have to tell
him I pulled you over and you're gonna
be like oh geez much more personal much
there's much more at stake that cop
knows if I beat this kid up that his
dad's gonna be screaming at me that
happened to me once in Chicago Falls
growing up I I think I rolled a stop in
the cop pull me over and was like
Crossland Tim's son I was like yeah he
was like get out of here I'm not talking
about getting a freebie I'm just saying
like I get pulled over by a cop and he
goes you were speeding and then I was I
wasn't speeding and I was like I'm sorry
I wasn't speaking I was exiting off onto
Belmont from Lake Shore Drive I was like
I'm 10 under the limit he goes tell to a
judge and he throws a ticket at me if we
were in a smaller community and this guy
knew there were repercussions for lying
and giving me a false ticket and my my
dad was going to show up at church and
be like what are you doing you're lying
they think twice about brutality or or
doing wrong more importantly even the
criminals who come in think twice
because they know they'll get ostracized
but we've become this big detached blob
where no one knows each other and no one
cares so I guess my point is you're
right you know cops can be very very
good so long as they feel that there is
something at risk if they if they go
against the community
selective enforcement arises out of the
fact that cops are like don't know you
don't care I'll never see you again
and then it just becomes callous
all right let's read some more where are
we at oh Noah Sandra says Hey guys
Phoenix ammunition is back on Twitter
that's cool glad to see it oh I like
this one Max Redick says Tim Sam Cedar
made a video saying Ian is an
anti-semite it's time to call out Sam so
tired of people like him I saw did you
see that I didn't see the video I
watched the first like 10 seconds they
were just laughing so I guess they're
having a good time which is good it's
because you said Kanye was going to save
the Jews save the Jews baby yeah I've
been thinking a lot about it was a claim
I made where I was like if you don't
believe in God you're not Jewish and
it's like well I think what happens is
because it's like there's a cultural
Jews and there's a religious Jews and
there's even a conflation within Judaism
that if you don't believe in God like
some the religious ones think the
culture was not enough I think
culturally here in Israelite you're from
the tribe of Jacob who's Israel everyone
is the Israelites but if you don't
believe in God then are you did you
follow the Jewish path if you you know
and I want I want to I think I think you
got to talk to a rabbi oh heck yeah let
me read this one powderpizzi says if the
judge rules the 290 000 ballots it's 298
000 belts broke chain of custody and are
invalid what happens with Blake's case
since he lost by less than that
that's a good question although I again
what's what's the remedy when the judge
says it's invalid is he can order a new
election somehow well so here's I think
I think the judge is going the judge is
probably going to say chain of Customs
broken that's bad the law doesn't give
me a remedy and unless you can prove
that either 17 000 in carries case or
125 000 in my case were changed not
doing anything what does the lawn need
to give him a remedy
if I was the judge and someone said
these ballots have no chain of custody
I'd say oh well then they're not valid
like the law requires actually that they
have chain of custody if they don't I
don't consider them about so remove them
and so the question then becomes if the
judge just says 290 000 ballots will be
removed from the total count go through
them and figure out who got what it
would throw every race into question
whose margin was less than 250 000 or
whatever well I think it's all of them I
think it's Maricopa County it would flip
everything Republican because these are
predominantly going to be Democrat votes
I don't know we talked a little bit
about this earlier I don't know if the
margin in Maricopa County Democrat
Republican is enough with that number to
change the results of your election if
290 000 were rejected right like it was
125 000 that means it needs to be like
two to one Democrat to Republican but I
don't think it was that much right
it was closer I have to do the math
would it be very interesting to see what
the judge rules right I mean
I if someone came to me and said do you
think the judge is going to rule in
favor of Carrie Lake I would say no I
just don't see it as possible if I had
to make a bad idea I'm not I'm not gonna
I wouldn't put a dollar on it I don't
trust that you know he's going to say
what you you're right he's going to say
it's gonna say it was really messed up
and
sorry about that and we should all be
outraged that there's gonna be no
accountability we talked about
accountability for for politicians for
what about the Maricopa County Board of
Supervisors like your one job was to
make sure that there was a smooth
election day Administration and they
failed to do it did they fail to do it
on purpose did they just I'm willing to
say like hey for thought the purposes of
this discussion assume that they're just
incompetent here's usually when you're
that incompetent you get fired let's
let's remove the politics from
everything and I'll tell you where the
problem is right now A Witness testified
they did not receive chain of custody
documents and we're told that they don't
exist
immediately there needs to be an
investigation because it's a matter of
law
will the judge make a criminal referral
for an investigation to find these chain
of custody documents I think the answer
is no
that's the problem that has nothing to
do with the with over 20 election I'm
just saying outright is a matter of
criminal law we need to know the chain
of custody documents exist they were
requested by one of the parties in the
election we're told they don't exist
what's going on
then there's the problem of if the
documents don't exist and there is a
criminal referral and someone is
criminally charged for not following the
law how could those votes then count
because you certainly couldn't come out
and say now hold on there a minute we
understand that the law was broken and
we have no evidence that these ballots
were legitimately cast but we're going
to count them anyway then the cost of
winning election is just for the
individual who wants to go to prison
that means in all if they don't solve
this in any future election an
individual can be like I'm willing to go
to prison if it means half a million
votes go to my candidate that's already
the structure of the law in so many
other cases in Arizona like ballot
harvesting in Arizona it's illegal right
I'm not allowed to go to a nursing home
or assisted living facility and collect
ballots and turn them in that would be
illegal but if someone did that even if
they got caught and prosecuted the
ballots that they illegally harvested
count I mean even if you could identify
them right there are legal votes as soon
as they get into the post office which
is really crazy right you think that an
illegally harvested ballot as soon as if
you could identify it wouldn't count no
in Arizona law it counts you can just
public uh this is corruption penalize
the person who did it the founding
fathers that did not intend for this to
be the system of gamesmanship whoever
can manipulate the numbers to the best
wins no it was of for and by the people
if we know definitively the will of the
people is not being followed through
then we have an obligation as the people
to remedy that but to come out and be
like well the law says there's nothing
we can do it's like you expect a
government of foreign by the people to
just be not of formed by the people
because of a statutory claim that's
insane
all right let's we'll we'll grab some
more here Brody Nevis says love the show
guys bring on the Tate Brothers also
Andrew is 36. I was watching a video
from him and he was talking about uh
dude I think I I haven't watched a lot
of Andrew Tate stuff
um I've known of him for a while and I
watched a couple videos but I have a
couple videos I've seen I really like he
had one where he's telling people to
like sign up to his program become a
member it costs money and all that and
that I'm like yeah yeah we get it but
the whole video is actually really good
he's like you're sitting there a loser
eating getting fat playing video games
when you could be winning you could be
changing your life you could be
improving and then he says something
like the rocket ship going to the Moon
doesn't stop halfway and chill for a
little bit it keeps going and it's hard
and that means you got to start working
hard now and not stop you can't give up
and I'm like oh yeah he's right yeah but
in Space the inertia will take you there
you don't have to keep your thrusters on
the whole time okay but you get the
point oh we're totally gonna debate
bring them on come on Andrew no I think
it was great like I mentioned when he
did the video where he says happiness is
irrelevant you have to eat if you're
happy or sad you wake up you do the
exact same thing you work hard and I'm
like yeah dudes he's completely right
that's that's motivation right yeah we
should go to Dubai and interview them
like he's like a whirlwind right I think
he's a kickboxer press one if he has to
do that I guess we have this next week
I kind of want to spend time with family
but January 3rd
it's it's just it would take like a
whole day to travel there yeah we do it
over the weekend
and then do a week in Dubai yeah that's
great you could set it up in Dubai
that'd be awesome uh you know I wouldn't
want to do it is because the the speech
laws they have are not in my opinion
conducive to a show like this yeah but
but it's the same like Bali you know
Indonesia has their own laws but Bali
has respect for tourists yeah if there's
a well there's a way Perhaps Perhaps
everyone press someone in the chat but I
think he also he also goes to uh Europe
too Romania yeah yeah oh dude I love
Romania so let's go to Romania I mean I
would I was there before too it's a
pretty awesome they have an awesome fast
food pizza joint I thought Romania was
awesome when I went there I enjoyed it
what are the what are the two big cities
there it's like Bucharest and what's the
other one I forgot brazov rajav I don't
know I loved it I thought it was so
fantastic great place by the way or we
could be like let's meet in the middle
let's go to Poland
I mean that'd be cool too I'd love to
I'd love to check that one out Damien
Simmons says Luke today I found out
about gold back currency that is
state-based New Hampshire uh et cetera
what is your uh for example what is your
input on cryptocurrency backed by gold
and silver or a state-backed crypto
um you know my sentiment always be
skeptical but when it comes to this
economy I think it's best to diversify
as much as you can and not put anything
in one particular basket we don't know
what's happening right now it's an
absolutely crazy Market don't trust
anyone and uh just try to have your
money all over the place because you
never know what's going to happen
kalishnikov says go watch the epa's new
diesel engine regulatory announcement
the emission requirement essentially
bans them and will force you to buy the
Chinese electric truck that doesn't work
probably
so way things go I guess you know
all right what do we got
Martin Edgar says I saw a show that
stated there was a noticeable polar
shift then the shift changed in the
opposite direction the culprit was
identified as the massive Construction
in China is causing the Earth to be
unbalanced
is that true
there are pole shifts you can watch the
the way the Earth's spinning it's kind
of like a it's not spinning completely
even so it's like wobbling and sometimes
you'll see the pole moving in like a
spiral I have no idea though to answer
that question
[ __ ] DJ says where are your shirts made
Luke
um I believe South America
right I don't know I gotta double check
if uh do you use spring uh I use a
number of different companies so I have
like three to four companies that I use
right now we're looking to uh we used to
work with a local shop in the United
States uh but they're no longer active
but if you have an active t-shirt store
that you're printing shirts in the
United States from the United States the
shirts are actually made uh in South
America I think it was either
um Ecuador I think I forgot exactly
which country but if you have a you have
a store here hit me up I would love to
work with an American Business I did
before I want to do it again I will say
it's hard
political t-shirts right so I insisted
on made in America blanks right why not
really hard you find an all a shade of
olive green that you like good luck
finding that shirt
and you know like 30 bucks 30 bucks if
you can get it or it might take six
months to get a us-made blank meanwhile
the stuff in Honduras the stuff in El
Salvador it's just that's you can't even
make Meanwhile my wife got to open a
t-shirt Factory my wife uh does vintage
shopping for our kids eight-year-olds
and six-year-olds and so when you get on
eBay and you get a shirt made in the 80s
or 90s invariably made in the USA made
in the USA we've just outsourced this
exactly we want to buy American it's
really hard yeah I think we should give
the the people the option to buy either
American or from South America
um so if you have a American t-shirt
business uh email me info we are
change.org and I want to do that again
so all right South America is America
too yeah South America is pretty awesome
too I love South America all right
everybody if you have not already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com
and this is it the finale the sign off
for 2022. I'll tell you what our plan is
we're going to spend time with family
we're gonna enjoy it we're gonna relax
for a little bit and just uh cool off
after Christmas and then uh I'm gonna go
up to New York City because we have big
Times Square Billboards up right now for
New Year's and we are going to the
official New Year's party where
supposedly all the big shots in New York
are going to be because we're invited
and I'm gonna really really enjoy that I
wonder how that will turn out we'll see
it'll be fun because Luke will be there
too and I I I'm great at events I tell a
lot of jokes this time Luke's not uh
sneaking in he's being invited in to the
the den of capital city that's rare I
usually get you know kicked out I'm
called uncommon at this point but
they're rare but I'm more common so uh
you know the rumor is the official New
Year's Eve party's gonna have a lot of
uh big shots Democrat players and things
like that and we're going as cordially
invited guests to enjoy the buffet and
watch the festivities and uh I imagine
that we will be calm and collecting
individuals but we'll see how that goes
so uh I just want to say thank you all
so much for your support in these past
few years and this year especially
allowing us to have that cultural
dominance at least a degree we do by
doing things like in Times Square and
becoming a member helps us continually
do more the next big project is we're
launching a coffee shop the building has
already been purchased we are now
um beginning the process of Designing
and planning out the coffee shop and the
hangout it's in West Virginia first
floor is going to be Cafe second floor
is going to be games and hangout third
floor is going to be a podcast Studio
where we can do Friday night special
events and members can hang out on the
first floor as we do the show and then
hopefully with the next year we have
four to ten new locations and we can
keep opening up these cultural spaces
where people can hang out meet each
other share ideas and we can build that
movement so thank you all so much you
can follow the show at timcastirl you
can follow me personally at timcast
Blake do you want to shout anything out
thanks for having me you guys are uh you
guys are great and really appreciate it
you got to come to Arizona more I I'm
able to join one with me and Carrie or
well you know with um if if Turning
Point USA is willing to have us here
absolutely yeah this this space they
built for us is incredible and um
considering the amount of space they do
have you know if there's ever another
opportunity where they can get us a
temporary setup we could definitely come
down and and do other things like that
we were planning on doing stuff like
that uh going to Miami we we did go to
Austin we have the mobile trailer and
everything but it's like you got you got
to find a place where you can hook up
get internet and do all that stuff
fortunately for us with Arizona Charlie
said we could build you a studio and get
your logo on the screen and we
definitely we definitely have to travel
more where can people find you on
Twitter at BG Masters uh Blake thank you
so much for coming on that was great
thank you for giving us your perspective
my website is Luke uncensored.com which
is getting the business from PayPal as
PayPal just announced that they're going
to be unsubscribing everyone from my
members area of course we had an
alternative a couple months ago set up
tell Peter Thiel be like teal what are
you doing I'm just joking he's not he's
no longer at PayPal but uh they're
unsubscribing everyone we set up an
alternative months ago but there's still
some members being signed up there
they're going to be forcefully cut off
so if you're on PayPal and you're signed
up to look uncensored.com go to that
website get off PayPal sign up on all on
our alternative we have a third
alternative that we're working on right
now lucansensored.com and right before
Christmas thank you PayPal really
appreciate it
um still the majority of my members were
on there so uh yeah that sucks so
well thanks for coming bro that was hot
this is fun good to see you man thank
you uh you guys when you go see your
family I hope you have a chance to do
this this holiday spend some time
listening to what they have to say
really just listen and remember if you
disagree if you start to get flush if
you want to talk politics whatever uh
that you're blessed just to be able to
have the conversation and be there for
them you know people are people are
waking up all over Earth
and I want to remind you about this
lovable wonderful Mr boccus keep bucko
in your thoughts I'm looking forward to
seeing Buckle I'll see him on the 2nd of
January I've been uh I've been looking
to get them stem cells uh a stem cell
treatment for his kidneys which were
underdeveloped for but the you know
congenital kidney uh issues so they say
that stem cells are more for like
chronic kidney issues and things so I
don't know if it's gonna work well he
does have chronic kidney disease okay so
there might be there might be a chance a
path forward here and I would love to
Pioneer some new regenerative medicine
and then publicize and popularize the
technology and save millions of more
cats and dogs and people across earth
and beyond all right take care of
yourself all right everybody thanks for
hanging out and we will see you all next
year
foreign